the state of emergency
that is affecting 17 states is being
expanded several states are now
declaring their own states of emergency
as around 1 000
gas stations are out of gas and the
strangest
creepiest thing about it is the media
keeps saying it's not happening
there was one tweet i saw earlier from a
public figure who said that in
asheville there they called 10 different
stations
gas stations and they're told there's no
gas but on the local news on npr nothing
new york times put out a tweet saying
there's no long lines
nothing meanwhile if you look at social
media you can see people are actually
starting to freak out now this may just
be panic buying and there are some
photos showing that maybe the case
or it could be that we are now going
into was it day five or so
it was last friday this hack occurred
they've shut it down and
people are well maybe the gas isn't
going out and i'll tell you what's
really interesting about this is there
were stories a few weeks ago
predicting that there was going to be a
gas shortage cnn reported on this the
guardian reported on this fox reported
on this and all of a sudden now this
this cyber attack happens which is
really really just crazy timing i should
say
uh you know at the very least but it's
more than just this gas shortage we've
got an escalating crisis now between
israel and gaza
a 13-story residential building was on
video you see it just
it blows up falls over things are
getting crazy out there
and now we're going to get weird wild
because apparently there is a solar
storm on the way expected to slam into
the planet i am not
exaggerating wow man talk about
it's been a crazy week we got a border
crisis we got inflation
we got mass exodus from the job market
we've got gas shortages there's a
massive drought in california a solar
storm is coming
war in the middle east jeez should we
talk about
some movies or something and get away
from all this now we're gonna get
serious
um perfect timing joining us today is uh
our good friend daniel turner who is an
expert on all things energy related you
want to introduce yourself yeah daniel
turner power of the future
um it is great to be here for the third
time and
when we when you invited me back which
i'm always grateful to be here this had
not yet happened so it really is
kind of crazy that that this is
happening and this is my forte
yeah yeah yeah so i mean there's like
you know talk of the green new deal and
and you know some other stories i was
like oh so we'll you know we'll we'll
have daniel come down
we'll talk about whatever because you
talk about everything else as well just
general politics and then it's like
we're like who do we have we need to get
somebody who's like good you know
talking about energy and
these oh we're good we we're good we're
all [ __ ] up
great uh it's kind of not a good thing
but uh no it's just good timing and so
it's great great to be back here thanks
for having me
again i have so many things to say i'm
gonna keep it short for now i'm ian
crossland coming at you from me and
crossland.net what's up everybody hello
and i'm excited to hear what ian has to
say tonight i'm just in the corner
pushing the buttons for the show
ladies and gentlemen before we get
started i want to give a shout out to
our sponsor safeandreadymeals.com
you'll see the link in the description
below click that link this is an
emergency food supply company and
i think it's very important to shout
them out i don't do it all the time and
i sincerely mean it when i say i shut
them up because i genuinely think it's
important
we have a bunch of these emergency food
supply bins
and i just love the the the arrogance
of some of these urban liberal types who
mock the idea that people would would
buy one of these emergencies with
supplies for themselves their friends
for their families take care of
themselves
we're not just in a pandemic with
lockdown in select areas i know some
states have reopened
where it's kind of silly i guess but
it's true we have the story about a
solar storm coming
we have a drought in california
sometimes adverse weather events happen
and you don't know if some
a tree will block the road you can't get
to the store these things are great to
have so go to safearmreadymills.com
you can see they've got four-week
emergency food supplies three-month
emergency food supplies we have a bunch
of these we have a ton of them
just recently there were heavy winds
knocked over some trees and we had to
get them cleared
sometimes that happens but now we're
dealing with these gas shortages there
have been stories about a shortage of
truck drivers if there's no truck
drivers there's no
there's no supplies there's no gas
coming in there's no food coming in
maybe nothing will happen maybe this is
just uh you know
it's a bad time and these things are all
coming together at the same time kind of
makes people freak out so don't freak
out
but i still think look if you're gonna
have a first aid kit in your house
because sometimes you get caught you
need antiseptic and that doesn't happen
all that much
well you gotta eat you gotta drink too
so you probably have some emergency food
so check it out at safeandreadymeals.com
think it's important for you guys to
have so sincerely please check them
check them out
don't forget to go to timcast.com and
become a member by clicking the members
only button
and you'll get access to our exclusive
members only segments from the members
area
man uh you know aside from all of those
other crazy things i'm mentioning we
still have censorship which is a very
real problem
as most of you know you know we got uh
my my personal facebook page has
been put under restrictions by facebook
so in the event that we get banned or
whatever you can find us here but with
your help by becoming a member
we're gonna do a lot to expand we're
looking at funding sitcoms we're gonna
do new shows we have to vlog obviously
we're gonna do a lot more and it's it's
thanks to you so let's just jump into
the news now
the first store we have from the daily
mail virginia georgia and north carolina
declare state of emergency over gas
shortages
after colonial pipeline hack as 1 000
fuel stations run dry in southeast
as people panic by they say ralph
northam and brian kemp
governors of virginia and georgia
declared a state of emergency on tuesday
on monday the governor of north carolina
roy cooper took a similar step to deal
with the fuel crisis
now they're going to mention a lot of
stuff most of us already know that the
pipeline was hacked it's ransomware it's
the largest pipeline in the country
i'm not entirely convinced i think we're
being lied to by the government
you know so we heard from the from a dhs
uh one of the people spokespers people
from dhs
there's no shortage we're seeing the new
york times say there's no long lines
there was another story i can't remember
which outlet was saying there's no long
lines everyone calmed down
but here's what i find strange the daily
mail is reporting it's panic buying
why why is it so heavily prominent in
north carolina is it just
something about people in north carolina
where they're more prone to panic and
buying
is it just panic buying i don't know
what do you think i don't know um
why north carolina particularly i will
say um in the region of the country
where i live and even
coming here tonight every gas station i
passed
had very long lines you don't live far
away from us no and
everybody knows where we live by the way
just you know and i filled up this
morning i got up early
because i saw the news last night and
i've been following this and i thought
you know what i'm just
uh gonna get up and first thing i did
was i took my car
uh i took the other car i took our gas
cans and i just filled up everything
just to
be safe so was i panic buying absolutely
i was
i'm sure a lot of people are doing the
same but it raises a larger question
about
infrastructure and and just rethink a
couple weeks ago when
the media cycle was easier right it's
amazing how crazy and how fast the media
cycle goes
when when the president introduced his
infrastructure bill and everyone began
joking saying
health care is infrastructure and poetry
is infrastructure and childhood dreams
are infrastructure
no this really is infrastructure like
infrastructure is infrastructure and
i think one of the biggest challenges i
have in my industry is that oil and gas
isn't always
sexy energy isn't always safe it's not
titillating it's not guns it's not
abortion
half the country hates it but but boy oh
boy is it really the lifeblood
of our economy and we're getting a taste
of what happens when when it's tinkered
with
this is what what freaks me out you saw
you you remember when greta tunberg was
like we're not talking about 2030 or
2022 we want right now
shut it down you got it look what's
happening when there's just
45 percent of supply on the on the south
on the east coast and the southeast
is disrupted this is what happens what
do you think would happen if they
actually got their way and shut down
everything yeah exactly
and and and we have a larger energy
infrastructure problem because most of
us
most of our refining happens in very
strategic areas right the refining
happens in the gulf
because historically we imported most of
our oil it was breed
cheaper to bring it in by barge so you
wanted it by the water and
the eastern seaboard because it was
coming from from
the middle east the eastern seaboard was
all really expensive real estate so
there was nowhere to go so they went
around florida
and they ended they ended up in the gulf
coast and that's where the refining is
and if you see a map
of the refineries and then a map of the
pipelines
pipelines everywhere but there really is
just one pipeline from the gulf coast
all the way and that's colonial pipeline
and it is a major pipeline
should we have built a second a third or
fourth absolutely should we have
refining in the northeast
we should but you also have to remember
we refine a lot in the south
because just in terms of chemistry
refining takes a lot of heat
it's less of less expensive and more
efficient
to refine something that is already warm
than to do it in a cold environment so
of course we were fine in this so this
is like the the barges bring the raw pat
the crude petroleum yes and his
refineries turn it into other stuff like
like gas
what else do they make the the crew that
comes out of the ground is refined into
literally hundreds of different products
so the re the reason why my
organization why i why we fight
sometimes a lot of these
uh renewable fuel standards and cafe
standards is not because we don't
believe in
in protecting the environment but
because if you are california for
example has over 50 different blends
of oil right for different for different
seasons for different vehicles
if your refinery and you have to produce
50 products think of a bartender
it's a lot easier just to be porn beers
but if you have to make 50 different
cocktails
well every time you've got a stop you've
got to switch well every time you do
that it drives up the price a little bit
a little bit a little bit
this one pipeline is bringing not just
one type of fuel but multiple types of
fuels and every state has their own
special blend
because a bunch of idiot politicians who
know nothing about energy
pass a law they're like we want the
blend to look like this and and and
everyone claps and that's so now they
need
so so this pipeline isn't just like one
big tube no it's like a bunch of small
tubes
in a big tube exactly a series of tubes
and they have said some of the smaller
ones and i forget what
there is a phrase for it and i don't
know if they're called the ancillary
ones the
the secondary ones but there is a phrase
form a lot of those the
i wish i remember the names a lot of
them are starting to come online
but the big jammies they're going to be
offline for a little while and that's
really really frightening so i'm hearing
people are tweeting out that we're
importing
gas now from europe we're trying to
bring in some energy is that true
well you know this is where energy gets
a little bit ugly because we've always
imported quote unquote because we refine
so for example some of the big energy
companies
companies really that don't like me
necessarily because they don't
they will say you shouldn't ban uh
imports from the middle east because we
refined those
those oil and this is bad for our
company and my response is
i'm not here for your company i'm here
what is good for america and if
importing oil from the middle east is
good for your company
what the heck do i care right so but if
you're a refiner
do you want to buy saudi oil at nine
dollars a barrel or do you want to buy
permian basin oil
at 45 a barrel i'll buy the saudi oil
well
that's not good for america they would
say well but it's good because then we
sell it cheaper into the american grid
at the expense of american energy
interests right so we do always
import quote unquote because we refine
it but not on the pacific coast
alaska cal think how crazy this is
alaska sends its oil
at this point now to china to be refined
to come back to america because we can't
we can't build a refinery in the
northwest they do that with a lot of
products we can't build refineries in
the pacific northwest
the very green groups that say we need
to get off fossil fuels are making us go
9 000 miles across the pacific to refine
in china
and by the way the chinese refineries
are environmental standards you would
not believe right
oh amazing oh gosh yes and then we barge
it back to america but no no you you
mean like
awful oh my god it sounded like you're
about to say they're so
great you would not believe how amazing
all the nine-year-old girls that work in
those refineries
they get paid at least a dollar a day
wow right exactly
so so china then benefits from the fact
that the green groups that don't allow
us
to build a refinery in america because
it's bad for the environment
same with the keystone pipeline right we
the very first conversation i was here
keystone had just gone by and shut it
down right is that oil not going to
houston of course it's going to houston
but it's going by train or by truck
i'm sorry man this is just infuriating
me because you know what i refer to this
today as a political drive-by
yeah you look at you look at msnbc and
cnn
you have all of all of those viewers and
voters
stopped watching yeah now that trump
isn't president anymore
they based their vote off of hating
somebody not for something
and the first thing we get now a lot of
people were in favor of joe biden
shutting down keystone
now keystone's shut down a lot of union
guys lost their jobs
and now we're we're dealing with this
crisis with with this pipeline
well they're coming out and saying
there's no shortage there's no shortage
i don't i don't i i'm sorry if i don't
believe them no i mean there's a
shortage at the gas station it's a fact
yes and for whatever reason maybe it's
panic or otherwise
they're not able to get the the fuel
back up there so even if it is panic
what do you think happens
panic should be should be baked into the
the the plan
we should know if there is a disruption
panic happens
well thanks to joe biden keystone's not
going to be available it makes me think
of don't buy them
we don't need you don't need a mask
remember that right when it came out
fauci
was like i thought she said that you
don't need them after two weeks they
didn't want to run on the masks
if they said there's an oil shortage
there would be a run on the oil they
don't want to run on the oil
and so and so it's good it's a good
point fauci came out
and later and admitted we were concerned
that medical professionals wouldn't get
it so we said that
and that's what i see now when the new
york times said there's no long lines
i think what happens is these people in
media no longer
is their job to inform the population so
they can make decisions for themselves
they've become the the self-appointed
nannies of the state
where the new york times is like just
tell them nothing's happening so they
stay home
but then people who pay attention like i
mean you had the biggest advantage
you're the energy guy daniel so when
this happened you probably got word
before anybody else
and you're like better go to the gas
station people are like what are you
doing don't mind me i'm just filling up
all these tanks
i did tell my family very early on that
they want to go and
i should have made it more of a public
announcement but yeah
like a lot of this is foreseeable no of
course i know but a lot of this
is foreseeable um and and there is a
supply issue right
keystone is a supply issue as you reduce
the supply of any good
and the demand does not diminish while
the price is going to escalate so
if you could say well i don't like
keystone it's bad for the environment
i'm saying that when you take it away
you are causing a supply concern
it's still coming like i said it's
coming by rail or it's coming by by car
uh by truck but that's expensive so we
are the goal it takes fuel to do that it
does of course it does yeah
the goal of the one of the jobs of the
president and this is where i do lay
this at the feet of president biden did
he cause the cyber
i lay this at the feet of president
biden because the president
we all know is extremely powerful and
can send signals that can tank the stock
market yeah or can make industries
go through the roof trump would tweet
and people would become millionaires or
lose a million dollars and that is the
power
and and and for for good or ill that is
the power of the president
joe biden has been sending signals since
the campaign
during transition and now as president
and he does not want to accept the
consequence of the signals so he
signaled that he has no problem with any
illegal immigrant coming across the
border what do we have now
four and five times the record they're
wearing those shirts
biden please let us know he sent a
signal right and
people listened and they responded he
sent a signal
that israel is not necessarily our
friend i know that's the next topic he
gave money back to the palestinians
right he re
sent restarted that funding he sent a
signal that israel is not our strategic
partner what's happening right now in
israel
he sent a signal on day one that energy
infrastructure is not important
he signed that keystone thing he sent a
signal and
people are responding i tweeted you know
i guess build back better means
crumbling infrastructure crisis of the
middle east
mass exodus from the workforce
unemployment and i get these lefties
being like
dude it's trump's fault or whatever and
i'm like oh it's a magical coincidence
that biden's policy ending executive
orders from donald trump the remain in
mexico
uh the the migrant protection protocols
remain in mexico policy
or shutting down keystone pipeline or
the 300
unemployment stimulus those policies
which he's enacted in the past several
months have no
impact on those those crises that are
happening right now
it's it's absurd to think that it's a
coincidence and we had what was it david
frum i think was it from
yeah who was like oh but everyone was
cheering for trump's piece in the
in the middle east and it's like oh and
then and then and then three months in
with joe biden
it's trump's fault now of course amazing
it's amazing it's a magical coincidence
it was it's it's as if they believe
donald trump was holding the country
together with a duct tape
and then as soon as he left now all the
problems are emerging sorry
2019 jim cramer cnn was it cnbc i think
best numbers of our lives the economy
was a booming don't get me wrong
he was spending a lot of money and that
bill always comes due but it's very
different compared to what we saw with
republicans and
democrats last year just cranking up the
stimulus now i gotta pay for it yeah now
now we have
this oil pipeline it's uh
crumbling infrastructure is an
understatement we have a real problem in
america politically because
we live in an instagram social media
twitter world
it's great for fast communication
communication and agility
but it's bad because candidates now
target their entire campaign around that
buildback better is a wonderful
alliterative bumper sticker
it is not policy right and all of his
proclamations and my dad told me joey
and he looked me in the eye and all
those little stories acute on the
campaign trail but now you actually have
to govern
and i don't think kind of like president
obama i don't think president biden
really wants to govern i think i think
he likes the uh
campaign i don't think confronting a guy
who was banging a straight razor on a
curb putting a rain barrel to get it all
rusty
i don't think that's the experience
someone needs to actually run the
country but it was a great story i guess
you know people had a laugh about it uh
what what did he call
what do you call that corn pop no he
called corn pop a name
do you remember what the name dude no no
no no no he's the variable he's
esther he called it esther williams yeah
which i'm i'm i'm
happy to say i'm too young i'm too young
to know what esther williams
who esther williams is or why that was
important i think i think
joe biden just wanted to be president
and then i'm sure that
you know he he stands he's probably
sitting in a wheelchair looking in the
mirror with a smile on his face
and people are running around frantic
behind him there's like papers flying
and the phone's ringing off the hook and
like
his assistant's hair's all frazzled and
they're like i don't know what to do
about israel but it's like
president come on man you know what i
bet he didn't even want to be president
because he didn't run in 2016.
made me think like he's he doesn't want
it he doesn't care he would have run a
hundred percent the vp comes out they go
right into it
seamless he didn't want i think the dnc
he hated trump yeah they they wrapped
him up he was like
i have a right he felt like a a force of
god like
this is my purpose here i must do this
he didn't want it he wasn't capable
he just went along he got pushed along
now say
donald trump really wanted yes and he
still does and he still does
um not like he was a perf like there's a
lot of people who think he's you know
they call him the god emperor
most of them joking but some people are
serious i think it would
we we would have been better off i
certainly think so but i guess the
the the the interests of the
military-industrial complex types and
the international monetary fund types
they weren't too happy with donald trump
being like america america
they're like no no no we we make money
off of you know exporting the reserve
currency and
putting guns in a bunch of different
countries i want to talk about something
really crazy check this out
so everybody knows there's a gas
shortage it's all over the news
as much as the new york times and some
other outlets might want to lie about it
but one when we're look when i'm looking
up stories trying to get more details on
this
something really interesting happens
when you google search gas shortage
what's the date you
find on some of these stories 1970. no
no
yeah for sure 1979 judy carter of course
of course people are
you know is it biden jr compared uh
biden to carter and it's like
what do you tweet like i guess i guess
my my tweet on this is aging like fine
wine no no no
no the the the hack happened on friday
what was what was friday was it the
seventh
that was the seventh yep the seventh so
you but you google google search gas
shortage you'll find stories going back
to
april 27th april 29th whoa whoa whoa
how was there a news cycle about gas
shortages
before the hack even happened and it's
one thing if it was like a few months
before they were like economists predict
no it's like a few days
before this happened we were getting
this prediction check out cnn business
coming this summer
gas stations running out of gas check
this out abc news
lack of truck drivers could lead to fuel
shortage this summer
and we've got this on fox business truck
driver i'm sorry yes it's from may 3rd
may 3rd
truck driver shortage could fuel spike
in gas prices
this to me is just very very interesting
timing
yeah does any one of those articles talk
about why there's a shortage in
truck drivers uh i mean we produced more
oil and gas than ever before
in the year 2019 and 2020 we never seem
to have a
shortage of truck drivers here's what
abc news says where do they go
as millions of americans return to
driving and planning summer road trips
experts are warning that some gas
stations could face fuel shortages quote
we are not looking at a shortage of
gasoline jeanette mcgee
a aaa spokesperson said in an interview
with abc news in fact we have ample
supply in the u.s
to get to the summer and the rest of the
year what the concern is right now is a
shortage of fuel truck drivers first
reported by cnn
the national truck i'm sorry the
national tank truck carriers
the industry's trade groups are between
20 and 25 percent of tank trucks in the
fleet
are parked last year during the pandemic
many of the drivers retired
or they went to different industries and
that created a shortage
truck drivers also need special training
to haul oil
and some driving schools have closed
amid the pandemic exacerbating the
problem
some areas have begun to see the effects
of the driver shortage particularly las
vegas
and northwest arkansas mcgee said
vacation hot spots near beaches or in
the mountains in particular
could feel the biggest effects someone
super chatted us this they said there's
a trucker shortage and it's gonna
it could result in supply shortages you
go to walmart
already what was it you were saying you
couldn't find bacon yeah we were looking
for bacon actually at costco the other
day you couldn't find baby find it
anywhere the four pack of bacon that's
like the most inexpensive bacon in the
world yeah
can't find a baby yeah so
i just find it absolutely fascinating
that we have these news stories
talking about this trucker shortage a
week ago
the cyber attack happens perhaps
coincidence but the the new
emergency regulations allow truck
drivers to drive
more than their allotted hours when did
that regulation get put into effect
after the cyber attack wow isn't it just
um i'm not asserting anything other than
oh i would what a very interesting
coincidence yeah we have to
let me just i'll just lay it out thank
you tim a week before the cyber attack
there aren't enough truck drivers warns
cnn
abc and fox this could result in rising
gas prices
and it could result in gasoline
shortages so how do you compensate how
would how would a normal person
compensate for a lack of drivers
well outside of any cyber attack you'd
say can we can we increase the amount of
hours
the oil haulers are allowed to drive
well there's a federal
federal regulation barring that uh well
i guess
coincidentally a national emergency or a
regional emergency 17 states in dc
and now the drivers are allowed to drive
over there over there a lot of times
you could eliminate that problem
altogether
if you just build pipelines i know isn't
it great right it's greener it's cheaper
it's safer it's it's yeah let me ask you
um
a lot of people proponents of the
keystone pipeline said that there's
actually more leaks
i think ian brought up you looked up
there were like 26 leaks from keystone
or something yeah
but are there you know i guess per
gallon are there more leaks from freight
and and trains oh absolutely and it's
well documented that
pipelines are by far safer cleaner
greener
um and what i care most about the more
cost efficient for the american consumer
undisputed and and and proof of the
matter is
um the amount of pipeline we have i mean
we have
we have enough pipelines to go to the
moon and back 10 times in america
right we have we have almost 3 million
miles worth of pipeline crisscrossing
this country
this place we're in probably has
multiple gas pipelines all throughout
the walls and people like i'm afraid of
pipelines
well you can't be that afraid because
you do go to your home
right so our pipeline capacity in
america is absurd
um but it is vulnerable clearly the
cyber attack so
keystone was going to be bringing in
from like the tar sands area alberta
canada yeah
the only reason why the president got
involved in keystone is because it
crossed an international border
right and now they're trying to use that
as a premise to shut down other
pipelines but he is not a czar
neither president nor trump nor nor
biden could go into a state and say i
want to shut down this pipeline within
the state of minnesota
that's not your prerogative he's going
to try to make it his prerogative and
this is where thank god we have the 10th
amendment and hopefully a court system
that upholds it and says but yeah i
don't know either
isn't uh i think canada is suing now
over this yeah as they should because
canada followed all of
the rules to get this pipeline approved
i don't know what the statute of
limitation is for a presidential
executive order they went through all
the necessary paperwork
starting years ago starting in the obama
administration obama never rejected it
he just kept it on the balance in
forever forever forever and then finally
trump became president
well they were hoping hillary would be
the one to have to give the big no
she didn't win trump won okay boom let's
get the pipeline started
is it so we had uh we had max kaiser and
stacey herbert on the show
last night and they were talking about
you know the us dollars the reserve
currency so we got to send it out
otherwise it's not the reserve currency
so they print this money they give it to
these foreign countries
to maintain the status as the reserve
currency i guess because the u.s doesn't
make a whole lot and we're being given
all the stuff because we print money
but i wonder if you know and you're the
energy guys so correct me if this is not
true or will not correct me but i'll
assert i'll ask the question
is the reason why the the democratic
establishment or the political
establishment
establishment in general doesn't want to
produce fossil fuels here
is because they want to use the us
reserve currency to have other countries
do it
and maintain you know our status abroad
um i would say that they don't want to
produce fossil fuels because it's one of
the biggest if not the biggest industry
that is not controlled by the state
and i think at this point the modern
democrat party is a statist
party and the fossil fuel and it's kind
of what obama did with with with health
care right he wanted to centralize
health care
under the purview of the federal
government because that's just what big
statists
think uh um venezuela has national
energy most of the european countries
energy exactly and i think they hate
this industry in particular
climate change and all that stuff is
just a very good vehicle
to accomplish what they want and what
they want is a state
run they look at they want to
nationalize the election system
you're right they like nationalizing and
centralizing
everything industry whatever we we had
this uh this phd pathologist guy on the
show um
and he was talking about like insect
species collapse
and you know the ramifications of human
population it's expansive there's
ocean acidification and i think that
crisis is absolutely exploited i know a
lot of conservatives don't agree they
think it's a lot of you know propaganda
i think it's i think it's a crisis and i
think it's exploited to the most absurd
degree notably
when we're talking about the border
crisis was it kamala harris was like the
crisis is caused by climate change
and it was funny because conservatives
predicted they're like camilarius is
going to go up in the podium and say
climate change caused the crisis
and she did it and it's just absolutely
absurd but they i believe they
absolutely this is their go-to
to seize power i'd be willing to bet has
more to do with
consolidating power within the state
like you mentioned it's just it's it's
not a federal controlled industry or
whatever
and they want that power and climate
change is a wonderful villain because it
is faceless it is nameless and
it and you are powerless against it so
for example you take someone like gavin
russon
who talks about the the fires in
california are caused
by climate change which is crazy because
southern oregon doesn't have that level
of fires
western nevada doesn't have that level
of fires southeast idaho
doesn't have southwest idaho doesn't
have that level why is just california
climate change well now i am i am
absolved of
forest management i am absolved of
running the state because it's climate
change
remember remember when they uh
criticized trump trump tweeted out you
know they've it's
poor poor forest management they're like
oh geez trump's so dumb
and there's actually an article from
like a year before it was like
california's not managing their forests
properly it's going to result in fires
not only that but i think one of the
wildfires was caused by electrical
companies
not shutting off the the grid pg e yeah
yeah so it like
sparked and like ignited things and
they're like well clearly that was
because of
you know the co2 levels but i'll tell
you this look i think
you know i talk to some very smart
people and they say there's concerns
about what happens we have too many
people
it's not it's you know a lot of people
think overpopulation is like we're all
standing shoulder to shoulder no it's
just
a lot of waste is produced and it can
upset the upset the delicate balance of
an ecosystem
unfortunately for the people who are
environmentalists and really advocating
for this stuff i got to say
you have lost the trust of so many
people when barack obama buys beachfront
property
when the when these wealthy investors go
and buy uh
miami beach property while complaining
that miami is sinking yeah so i'm sorry
dude it's really hard to generate trust
and if you if you're somebody who wants
you know republican
these democrats are like republicans got
to get on board and fight climate change
well you got to start with
you know your your thought leaders not
flying in private jets
not owning massive 50 bedroom homes and
not buying this beachfront property
i saw this video it was actually really
compelling
not in the way i think a lot of
conservatives expected it to be for me
there's a guy he's a financial guy and
he says the one thing that he believes
disproves climate change
is that in miami beach they're still
selling these multi-million dollar
expensive properties
and these very wealthy individuals who
are supposed to be in the know are
buying them on 30-year mortgages
and he says how is it when they receive
like a prospectus or like an investment
packet
it doesn't say warning in in ten years
this will be underwater and worth
zero how is that when i saw that what it
said to me was
these people either don't believe their
own their own pitches
or they're absolutely just willing to
exploit people by buying property they
know it's going to be bunk and then
selling it later
or just going like extracting as much as
they can from the system
as they ride it all the way to the
gutter well i mean this administration
is is making a huge push that
all industry all business has to have a
climate
component and and the products you
create whatever you manufacture
the the the effect on the climate has to
be built into price
real estate seems to be exempt from that
so you're absolutely right like if
you're bank of america and you're like
we can't finance this because it's bad
for climate change well you gave a
30-year mortgage on a house in
an area that's going to be underwater
and 15. is that a good investment of
your money
so you're you're right like i'm i'm not
saying that this should happen but i'm
saying it's funny that the banks are not
pricing real estate
into this industry i got a solution
what's the regulatory body that deals
with the
would that be the sec or would it be the
ft it would be the ftc would it with uh
it wouldn't be the sec dealing with like
um when a bank gives out a bunk
loan isn't that fdic fdic i think
that's insurance okay how about this
here's here's what i got to say
sec banking security securities in
exchange that's a security imagine
um maybe a little bit of both of ftc uh
how about this
conservatives and democrats can come
together okay not the ultra-rich
property owners just the regular
working-class people disagree
and here's one issue they can come
together on
these banks that are giving out loans on
these properties in miami beach
on 30-year mortgages or even 15-year
mortgages
how about we send the feds after them
for fraud
and i think the democrats who think
climate change is a serious problem
we've got 12 years left
would agree and i think the
conservatives who see these people as
exploiting the
the crisis in order to make for personal
gain hey why not
if these people want to come out and say
you know oh there's a big crisis
but then they're selling these expensive
properties and giving out these loans
send the federation they'll give them a
million dollar loan
they're like you know what if it goes
underwater in 15 years my dollar is
going to be worth 100 million dollars
anyway
because of inflation so i'll just pay
off that loan not even calculated risk
loss i'd be willing to bet the banks are
like
look in the event that it's under water
in 15 years we just get the taxpayer to
bail it out you're fine
yeah it'll be it'll be a crisis fema
will come in they'll start building
uh these emergency sea walls for you you
don't got to worry about a thing and it
won't come out of your pocket
the government will keep printing money
for you and the banks it's the poor
people who got to work extra hard to get
that emergency
you know the emergency uh circumstance
solved yeah
there's just there's there's not
physical evidence of climate change
and now someone is listening to this
right now and their head is about to
explode media matters just clipped that
and they're like
exactly but but i mean they'll they'll
show you the california wildfires
they'll talk about
and we hear this phrase all the time
especially from this administration the
severity and the intensity and the
frequency of storms
if you look at 30-year of tornadoes of
hurricanes
there is no more severity intensity or
frequency of storms that the data is is
fairly flat
there are bad years absolutely there are
some really bad years there are some
empty years but but over 30 40 50 years
the data is
is pretty evident and for me the biggest
evidence that that this climate change
thing is used
i'm not saying climate change doesn't
exist i'm saying the way it is it is
used by the left for political purposes
for me the biggest evidence is that the
same bodies that have been talking about
climate change
for most of my life now i was a
sophomore in high school the first time
i heard about global warming
and and united nations environmental
program unip
you can still see the article online
they talk about uh
we have 10 years left to fix this 1989
shows you my age by the year 2000
the maldives were going to be underwater
they said a half of bangladesh was going
to be underwater
they talked about huge catastrophe not
only did it not come true
but those agencies have never said why
their data was so wrong what formulation
did they use what what algorithms
what calculation and modeling did they
use and how did they fix it
i've never been able to see their fixed
show your work when
they don't when i was in grade school
they had us go over uh a prediction for
peak oil consumption
yeah jimmy carter said it was by the
year 2076 when he was running for
reelection
i i don't remember exactly but i think
it was like 2010 it was like the bell
curve was crap like the curve was
crashing and it was like there's no oil
left and that's when we're screwed i
grew up thinking
oil and gas were finite commodities that
would be exhausted i'm at the point now
that i think they're
not infinite but they're clearly
replenishing because we find more oil
and gas every time we turn around
it's ridiculous i think there's probably
a lot yes but i also think that
um we've been able to synthesize it and
so
this idea that we have to dramatically
transform the whole planet
because of uh you know because of the
fear of like piqua or whatever
we could synthesize it and maintain our
current infrastructure yeah may just be
different
i i have no problem with going green as
a concept i i i have nothing against
solar and wind
one of the things i try to do is say we
have to see the costs and not just the
physical dollar costs
but but the costs to human flourishing
if we do this because there is going to
be a lot of suffering you mentioned
right now
when when greta said i'm talking right
now no more oil and gas
well there's a lot of people right now
who are experiencing it millions would
die
literally overnight no no i mean
literally
the people who require insulin it's got
to be refrigerated
you shut what do what do these people
think the power plants run on
you know farts some smug sense of self
satisfaction of these
oh we'll build solar plants at night how
do you have no batteries
i love the idea of new technology i
don't like the idea of holding back
development
for the sake of existing you know i
don't like the argument of like oh no we
gotta protect jobs
we do i think we should have new
technology nuclear fusion whatever
but this idea that you can come out
right now and just shut it down oh okay
well people will starve to death
people will freeze to death diabetics
will all die because they don't have
refrigerator
won't be able to refrigerate their
insulin we've never advanced as a
society
by banning something that is currently
in use we offer better alternatives and
the marketplace and a free
people adopt them freely we have never
said that this is the way to go and
therefore this is now illegal
i think carbon recapture is really the
future like you can change the climate
climate change you can add or reduce
carbon in the atmosphere hence
changing the climate climate change the
carbon is a beautiful commodity here we
go and it's there in the atmosphere for
us to condense
and turn to graphene reconvert it back
into fuel
and you know what you're talking about
and then you have and i know he's old
and i hate to pick on him but then you
have the president of the united states
on earth day say
i'm working with vladimir putin and
we're going to try to get all the carbon
out of space
and everyone just claps let alone the
fact that he has a mask on on the zoom
call
and you say you're going to get all the
carbon out of space
what the heck does that mean john kerry
said we are going to make sure that
there is no carbon by the year 2030.
well plants really don't like that
humans
really don't like that plan we're carbon
based i think if we're smart we'll start
recapturing the carbon and then we're
actually going to be competing with the
plants and we're going to make sure that
we don't take too much of it out of the
atmosphere
and it'll be like climate change in the
other direction so we're going to have
to find a balance
with producing and reusing along with
the plants
we talk about carbon like it's like it's
evil we talk about carbon like it's like
it's
it's so bizarre these are the most such
unscientific people
i think i know what it is it's
silicon-based life-forms the aliens they
don't like carbon-based life-forms oh so
they're propaganda campaign cards
there's all this ufo stuff
non-stop every time you turn around
there's another ufo i want to mention
something as an aside real quick i just
got to do it um
joe biden said to take a shotgun and
fire it into the air
and i don't know if you guys know it's
just totally derailed for a second
boogie who's a big youtuber has a
warrant a felony warrant for aggravated
assault because some guy came to his
house
and he fired his gun into the air you
can't do that and he lives near a school
so that's
aggravated assault but the funny thing
is a lot of people are pointing out like
joe biden said to do it
honestly i wonder if that defense would
work
the president said fire a gun into the
air and so the guy was like i got scared
so i did what the president said to do
it wasn't a shotgun but anyway i digress
joe biden says
insane things and it quite possibly has
a result
in this country on people thinking and
doing insane and a lot of these people
now have positions of power so they say
things like we need to get off fossil
fuels
now we need to give every american free
health care
now well there there are real
consequences to again
alliterative bumper sticker campaigns
and now we need to be adults and we need
to say
what does it mean if we got off fossil
fuels now millions are suffering through
it and i
and i feel for them i'm gonna tell you
i'm gonna go totally cliche
stereotypical this is communism check
out the story from
cnbc all eyes are on this inflation
number which could have the biggest
gain in nearly a decade they say the
consumer price index for april
will be reported on wednesday at 8 30
a.m and is expected to be the hottest
in nearly 10 years economists have said
the jump in inflation looks larger
because the base effects of last year
when prices were weak to the pandemic
shutdowns the specter of inflation has
been spooking investors
so any surprise the upside could uh
surprise
the upside could stress the market this
inflation thing
what is joe biden doing they're mass
printing money mass
spending bill they're policies these are
biden policies that have caused people
to not want to work anymore it's
democrats republicans together who have
mass printed money
i was in favor i said look when the 15
days below the spread
good faith effort everyone kind of
agreed we got this crisis and it turned
it into a year and a half
you know a year and three months and so
the economy was just on in flames and
they kept printing money like crazy
what's happening now is if let's say
let's say uh ian
slept on a couch for a week and did no
work and then i worked 40 hours that
week and made 500
ian has no money i have 500 the
government comes in
and starts mass printing money giving
this you know very heavy uh
unemployment ian as somebody who's lying
around hasn't produced any value for the
system
i as someone who worked 40 hours a week
has but now ian has buying power out of
nowhere
which dilutes my buying power so they're
effectively
it's effectively communism and i'm not
saying like literally it's communism but
you have this very authoritarian
government
you have them pushing absurd policies
that are like shutting down pipelines
causing economic
damage and then the mass printing of
money and then this unemployment scheme
and it's just basically stripping away
the buying power from working americans
and giving it to people who
aren't producing and aren't working yeah
that's that's that's what we were warned
about we've got like a ratio because if
i had zero and you had 500
and then they gave everybody 500 so even
this is an argument for ubi not being
functional
you'd have a thousand i've had 500 i now
have 50 of your purchasing power before
i had zero percent right
that's a huge increase so that means
think about it this way
if i made 40 widgets and you made zero
and then i get 500 and you get uh
and you get 500. so i have a thousand
total they just gave you the ability to
take 20 of my widgets away even though i
made them and you made nothing
that's what's happening right now with
all of this spending you
you add all of this you look at what's
going on and it seems like
you're not to be too conspiratorial
anything like that no but maybe these
conservatives who are like you know
hannity or rush bang on the table saying
they hate america they're communists
they work completely wrong
just do you think the authoritarians and
the communists are gonna come out and be
like we want to
redistribute wealth from working-class
people to poor people
so we can court you know normalize we
want to take away your ability to drive
we don't want you to have the
independence to to spend your own money
we want to tax the poor they're not
going to come out and say that i mean
bloomberg
did come out and say tax the poor yeah
but they're not going to come out and
say that they don't know what's good for
them they're going to come out and go
oh oh gee we got to give everybody
unemployment uh
it's it's so it's so sad that the
economy was shut down
and then it's only the blue states that
are still shutting down here's what gets
really crazy
this is what i think is going to be
freaking people out
you see all these signs from these fast
food restaurants where they're like we
quit we won't work here anymore
you saw those we talked about the other
day there's a dollar general where it
says we refuse to work for these wages
in these red states a bunch of the
republican governors announced they will
not be taking any money from biden
this 300 unemployment they ain't going
to take it because people don't want to
work
because you get 16 an hour unemployment
so imagine you live
in mississippi where i think it's one of
the states where they're doing this
and your unemployment's getting caught
off you're like okay i better go i i
better go get a job
so you go down to local uh mcdonald's or
whatever and you apply for a job and
they're like 13 bucks an hour and you're
like
better than nothing then some dude shows
up and he's got like a pink
sweater tied over his shoulders and like
a green pastel shirt and he's got
aviators on and his hair slicked back
and he walks in he goes i'll take the
number ten you know give me two number
tens and let me like two
apple pies and two mcflurries you know
what screw it he dishes out a bunch of
cash
and this guy who's working in
mississippi who's not getting
the the unemployment sees this guy who
comes from a blue state that is
the guy in the blue state did no work
he's in the analogy i gave the guy who
did nothing
and now has has been given the buying
power of the guy who's doing work
the people in red states are going to be
like nah you come in here with that
money
that was printed that strips our buying
power away
and then buy from us while we work that
means these red states where people are
working
are going to be in effect producing free
of charge
for the blue states especially when it
comes to goods that are transported
across state lines so imagine you work
in mississippi
and you're making uh i don't know what
they made what are they going to be
some what kind of fruit how about uh
georgia they do peaches right peaches
yeah peaches in georgia
so i don't know if george is one of
these states but let's say they're like
okay no unemployment for you
you got to get a job somebody goes i'm
gonna go grow peaches then the peaches
get shipped up to new york where the
people are not working
and they're getting free money from the
federal government while you
work on a farm to make those peaches for
13 bucks an hour
they're getting 16 bucks an hour doing
nothing and getting the fruits of your
labor
literally so you mentioned sorry let me
jump in here because i love the 10th
amendment
and this is something that you mentioned
uh before and i don't think any of our
guests have ever really mentioned the
10th amendment the 10th amendment is so
important for allowing the states to do
what the federal government is not
specifically supposed to do
so i wonder this looks like a good
application of the 10th amendment
but to me it also looks like it could be
starting the roots of a civil war
that's a great point and and and yes
i i agree with you i'm i think the way
out of our current
problems of an all-powerful dc is
federalism meaning
those powers that are not specifically
in the constitution enumerated for the
federal government belong to the states
but that is kind of how you begin a bit
of a
of of secession movements and there's a
lot of that in america but there
has to be some pushback and i don't
think it should come from the people i
think it should become
coming from the governors so like you
said the governors are not going to take
cash
governors should uh you know you meant
your example which i thought was
was really good and really illustrative
of what's going on
i think there's another factor if i
could add it on is you want to get a job
you go to the mcdonald's
but the vast majority of americans work
in small businesses
and with 150 000 illegals crossing the
border every day i don't need to pay 13
an hour i can charge this guy six and
that's what's going to happen so now i
can't even get a job for 13
an hour because the market is flooded by
cheap labor so imagine
the crisis you just said but the labor
is the other and our labor is not
constant our
labor pool is growing tremendously
with no consequence so why are you going
to work for 13
an hour when why am i going to hire you
for 13 when joe biden says
it's totally cool to hire that guy for
half well we saw that when
it's dignity under donald trump there
was a raid on a bunch of chicken
processing plants
and i think what is it like six to eight
hundred uh illegal immigrants were
arrested and deported
and then local news went down they had
hiring fairs
and they saw a bunch of people you know
a diverse group of people
showing up and they were like why are
these people coming for a job and they
asked one guy and they were like
why would you want to work for these low
wages and he goes pays 14 bucks an hour
it's more than i was getting at the gas
station so
these companies exploit porous borders
absolutely it's always been that way
that's why bernie sanders in 2015 said
it is a koch brothers proposal to have
open borders
now the left is all for it because they
support industrialists i guess
yeah that's the poi that's the
democratic party no the republicans are
trash
oh absolutely there's like a handful of
good ones i guess yeah but they're not
doing anything either
i feel like uh i remember when dylan
radigen did that epic rant i know if you
remember it back in like 2013 where he
said
the democrats the republicans are
burning the system down while democrats
are kicking the can down the road for
future generations
and i'm like kind of feels like it's
inverted at this point republicans are
just sitting there twiddling their
thumbs
watching you know just kicking the can
down the road ignoring the problems
while the democrats are actively burning
the system down
and i think it's because they want to
extra they feel the system is crumbling
so they want to extract as much as they
can for themselves individually
before it all comes tumbling down there
was a stick i saw from the 2020
tax returns that blew my mind and it was
i believe it was 62 percent of those who
filed having made more than 500 thousand
dollars
62 were registered as democrats oh yeah
yeah i mean
so in in the course of my lifetime
you're right it has flip-flopped
they are the party of the rich they are
the party of the big banks they are the
party of open borders
and the republicans and now they're the
party of censorship where it was when i
was a kid
right it was that shouldn't be on tv and
where our morals and the answer was if
you don't like a churn the channel
now the right is the one saying well if
you don't like it turn the channel on
the left is saying that shouldn't be
allowed on tv you can't
well i think it was true it's amazing i
think the the culture war was was
looming and i think
donald trump and bernie sanders were
insurgents trying to break into their
parties
bernie's much too weak and so the
democrats grabbed him by the throat and
said
you know shut up or else and he said
okay i'm so sorry and donald trump was
like no
no and he like kicking tables over and
he's like flipping tables and
you know slamming glasses on the ground
trump's kind of guy so i've said it
before i think when he got elected
the establishment was like okay donald
you won here's the plan he went no
i don't think so and they're like you're
gonna play ball he's like no i'm not
they're like okay he's a russian spy
yeah there you go oh i agree with you
and bernie as you mentioned uh
earlier you were talking about how going
back quickly to the climate change issue
how
there is such hypocrisy of the people
who push these causes and the opulent
life they live for me he's a wonderful
example i mean does he have an opulent
life maybe not but he does have three
houses four if you include his
you know i i don't have four houses now
if you really believed in the human
ability of anthropo anthropomorphic uh
climate change or global warming aegw
and you believe your actions are causing
this well your action of maintaining and
traveling to
four different homes has a carbon
footprint is
bernie going to give it up no neither is
anyone on that side
so for me when people like bernie's a
communist i'm like he's not really a
communist no he is he is
he no he's he's a communist party
official right because at the height of
the soviet union the party leaders never
wanted for caviar vodka
the people were dying in the streets but
they had a very good life and they
supported and toast the system
bernie is a party leader i really think
that one of the greatest moments in the
history of
government economics or just humidity in
general was when maduro was giving a
speech to his starving people in
venezuela
and he pulls an empanada out of a drawer
and he takes a big bite
because not only was it like insult to
injury that
people are starving and you're eating in
front of him but why did he have an
empanada
in his desk drawer in his office like
that no no no no like
hold on maybe i understand you having
some cookies or crackers like
in it somewhere else but it's his work
desk where he's giving his speech from
and he likes looking at the camera he
leans in and he pulls an empanada out of
a drawer
that's weird that's like someone having
like an unwrapped snickers in their
pocket yeah
like what is like walking around
spaghetti in your pocket it's like a
weird thing to do
but you gotta love the corruption of
these far leftists and with venezuela
you mentioned maduro the richest person
in venezuela is hugo chavez's uh
uh ex-wife dead widow right
is the richest person in venezuela so
when you were saying earlier about those
who have
purchasing power but have done nothing
to earn it that is taken to the extreme
what has she done to be working as a man
tens of billions of dollars she hasn't
done produced
uh is it fair that is it quote unquote
fair that that jeff bezos is worth 200
million dollars and am i jealous he just
bought a 500 million dollar
sailing event by the way wow is it funny
though that
we are actually arguing from the left on
this point
that these communists and socialists
have done nothing to produce
the wealth and the access that they hold
and we are angry the workers have had
their values stripped away by a crop
system
exactly maybe that's that
you're right that is a brilliant that's
a great point yeah no now we sound like
old school lefties we sound we we we
sound like
like old union uh uh uh uh
what's his name of jimmy hoffa this this
is the problem i have with us with with
the unions with the left is that
they've clearly been corrupted by the
the by the industrialists by the
industry by the by the by the corrupt by
the crony capitalists by the
establishment politicians
who just want to extract value from the
working class and the problem is
the younger leftists aren't experienced
enough to understand they're being
exploited and they just play right into
it
so it's funny when you see all of these
people who voted for joe biden
they're young people who don't
understand who they're voting for and
i'm like you're voting for joe biden
yeah well trump's a fascist i was like
do you have any idea who you're talking
about with joe biden
he he was overseeing iraq for the bite
for the obama administration
and his brother gets his contracts to
build you know you know in iraq becoming
a millionaire
the obama administration killed a bunch
of people started a bunch of wars
i don't care if you don't like trump but
stop pretending like biden is in any way
good
yeah and and no that's that that's a
great point my idea just went right out
of my head i was
talking we talked about oh and and
purchasing power so you said the way we
were talking about
you know we now sound like leftists
talking about exploiting the workers
as opposed to you know the
industrialists or the the
the people that own all the the wealth
the left has become the right i lost my
train of thought sorry i'll get back to
you
the left has become the right point
that's why i've had like a couple
jokes where i've been like you know it's
it's about time the workers
stood up to the exploitation of the
establishment politics and maybe
maybe the the the workers of the world
should unite and push me back
oh and yes and that's that was sorry am
i cutting you off no go ahead
well that's that was my point of of the
value of you used the phrase a couple
times of like paying into the system or
buying into the system or contributing
to the system
and that was a little bit of of what i
found fascinating with the early
occupy wall street movement and i
remember one of the leaders of it and
i'm not making fun of the guy
but he was talking about his huge
student loan debt because he had gotten
advanced degrees in puppetry
and and he couldn't pay off his student
loans and that's the problem i have with
elizabeth warren's proposal of paying
off student loans
is you value very highly your degree in
medieval literature
you value to the point of three hundred
thousand dollars in debt at yale
that doesn't mean society or the markets
or and that doesn't mean therefore that
i should have to pay off your debt
i i i i was down there locked by wall
street yeah that's why i mentioned
that's why i didn't know this
i knew it all went together and i was so
mad i lost my train of thought earlier
under employed puppeteer joins by wall
street
and they say a few years ago he
graduated from the nyc
teaching fellows program where he's a
full-time drama teacher a public teacher
he's a country school 35 000 in student
loans
and now he's like give me money i saw a
meme
where someone was like it you know these
these
bourgeois leftists are like oh you
should pay off our student loan debt
because
just because you were able to pay your
debt doesn't mean we should suffer
and i was just like i think asking the
working class to pay
the debts of the the wealthiest uh the
highest salary earners in the country is
like pretty
far right and people are like oh
like what do you call it i guess that
far right the right answer but what do
you call it
when the ultra wealthy i shouldn't say
ultra rough because that's like the
point one percent
what do you call it when the when the
rich people the the highest salary
earners in the country
demand of the working class and the poor
to
pay their debts for them yeah slavery i
guess communists do that right
it's like roman old roman slavery yeah
yeah yeah your citizens and then
everyone else
the the period or whatever the greeks i
mean it was just you had like citizens
and then you had everyone else in
society and they would basically work
for the citizens
yeah and the greek philosopher king
system gave us
really the foundation of western thought
right but they did have a whole boatload
of slaves
to make that system keep that system
afloat and so i don't
i'm i've always had a little thing
against academia there's a great quote
by fulton sheen a
famous catholic uh priest up for
sainthood and he has this funny quote he
says that intelligencia
is uh when you educate someone beyond
his intelligence
and i think that's a great quote right
so i've always had a problem a little
bit with the intelligentsia
again go get your phd in in medieval
poetry that's fascinating
but it doesn't really contribute to
society and anything other than the
intellectual way
and if someone is not sustaining your
livelihood as a medieval poetry
professor
then it is it is communism it is a form
of slavery really or totalitarianism to
then come to the working class and say
and therefore now you must and that's
what people do
and that is what has happened so it's
really funny that
in this sense the trump supporters were
far left they wanted the union jobs back
they wanted the jobs brought back to the
country they wanted manufacturing jobs
they wanted to work
they were tired of being exploited by
the ultra elites the people who are
rigging the system
and the leftists are the college
graduates who want the poor people to
pay their bills
and want the establishment to go bomb
other countries not all the leftists a
lot about this don't like any of that
stuff but they're willing to support it
yeah
so i think one of the greatest things
that i'm sorry that's a um
what's a collaborator is the right word
um conspirator conspirators
conspirators that's what they would say
so these leftists these dsa types
who voted for biden are conspirators in
their own terminology
and based on the ideology of the trump
supporters they're actually further left
than they are
in the sense that they support the
workers rights they're not communists
though
even so as as center right defending
workers
they're still somehow further left than
the leftists who are like
bourgeois right authoritarians yeah and
their salon right like like
sipping expensive liqueurs and and
talking lofty thoughts i remember the
first job i got in a campaign um the
campaign manager said
we don't need anyone here who wants to
sit in a room and think
lofty thoughts like the first job was we
have to blow up balloons
right and and it's not fun to blow up 5
000 balloons but someone has to do it
but you meet a lot of these campaign
people who are like
well i really love to think about like
trade policy okay kid you know what
we need you to set up chairs and blow up
balloons um
and we have a lot of that we have a lot
of the the people who want to think
lofty thoughts and they want other
people
to finance it and and there's going to
be some violent pushback if
that movement grows yeah they're being
paid for college alone
historically there's been like hammurabi
for instance one of the greatest kings
in
babylonian king canceled all debt and it
just
infuriated the elite they wanted they
hated it but he was such a good
powerful smart guy that he didn't get
assassinated normally the elite will try
and assassinate you if you do that the
people
loved him and then the community thrived
as a result so you get these people like
kennedy for instance who wanted to break
up the cia's power
unfortunately he was sitting in the
white house they knew where he was it's
easy to follow him track him kill him
uh maybe maybe you get these populist
debt campaign kennedy
kennedy what about are you talking about
kennedy john f kennedy he was kind of a
populist
i don't know if he was going to cancel
death but he wanted to kind of break up
he wanted to work with the central banks
yeah he wanted a and they got shot by a
crazy disrupt the yeah yeah how
what a horrible coincidence that was um
so i i don't know unless you've got
something to show me i don't know what
else to say
i think we're in a debt situation that's
spiraling and we do need to cancel debt
some debt maybe not all debt and we need
to figure it out sustainably interest
rates maybe
cancel interest rate debt yeah cancel
the interest rates on the student loan
debt so they still got to pay down what
they received but it's not going to
start stacking up
interest rates and stuff i know people
who took out like 35k in student loans
and now oh 70 grand yeah cancel that
yeah that's ridiculous pay back what you
were given and and we got to talk about
interest and inflation that's another
problem
because taking out 35k sitting on it
until inflation hits and then paying
back
it down but you can only have a debt
problem
if you have a spending problem and i
think one of the one of the
the consequences for example the first
round of the stimulus one of the biggest
beneficiaries was foot locker
people took their fourteen hundred
dollar checks and they bought new
sneakers
right the government says we're going to
give people 1400 so they can pay their
mortgage so they can buy
formula for the baby is it
wrong am i going to force a law that
says how you have to spend your money
i don't know but how can you continue to
put the country in debt
and then i know that people have this
spending tendency so that's why i am
i am a star of the beast approach well
let's get real then
one of the biggest problems of this
country is the
spoiled attitude of every single
american i think
you know 90 of this country are spoiled
or entitled to a degree
but some obviously more than others so
obviously conservatives are
substantially less
spoiled than democrats but still spoiled
i think it's a pretty
decent gap but there are a lot of people
who are entitled to the comforts and
luxuries of modern living
so i look at what's going on with the
these you know fast food
you know getting shut down people want
to work there and i'm like don't eat
that garbage food
you know it's not hard i think you know
people were tweeting at me when i
tweeted this
pictures of like someone threw some
onions and carrots and some beef into a
pot cooked it and they were like it was
cheaper
and it fed more people and it was better
for you we're addicted to these luxuries
of getting greasy garbage salt food for
a couple bucks
at a faster restaurant we don't want it
people got to figure out how to survive
they got to get back to the basics we
have a garden out front
so we have you know i was reading
something interesting
a lot of environmentalists talk about
this that the biggest crop in the
country is grass
everybody has a lawn growing grass all
we do is we spend money to get rid of it
we cut it and throat in the
compost or whatever why not have gardens
why not have a front garden where you
can grow some vegetables
in for your area and then subsidize
yourself in a way that you're not having
to buy as much from these stores so
you're growing your own food
man growing your own food is amazing get
some chickens maybe they lay eggs and
they're hilarious
they're filthy and dumb but it's fun to
watch them do their chicken stuff
and you get eggs they eat bugs eat grass
and then you give them some feed
and you get eggs every day right so i i
look at a lot of these problems and i'm
like well you know what look man
i would be more than happy to live in a
van down by the river and go fishing
you know i i do this because i want to
and if at any point i couldn't do it i'd
say okay fine i've got no problem with a
van live in a van down by the river
but a lot of people are just too
entitled they won't give up their modern
comforts
now a lot of these lazy gluttonous
city-dwelling people are forced to
sort of reconcile with this way of life
they can't they can't sustain anymore
i think if you look at the pandemic in
the lockdowns conservatives i hear it
from a lot of these people in rural
areas
not as not as affected you're in the
middle of nowhere there's no
there's no outdoor mask mandates you're
living your life the way you normally do
your neighbor is kind of far away you
still go talk to him
in the cities it's panic yeah you're in
a you're in a cubicle you can't go
outside it's solitary confinement people
are fleeing the cities they want to live
this way anymore they can't get supplies
in the cities gas is skyrocketing gas
shortages
people in the country like what did you
just say earlier in the show ian you're
isolated from what was going on in the
cities
no i don't remember saying that what do
you mean you were mentioning something
about
these people who have been like uh you
know locked up in their apartments they
can't get out
and you're maybe before the show and
you're like isolated from that because
we're out in the middle of nowhere oh
yeah i haven't experienced it in a while
i was in the city for like 15 years you
know new york chicago los angeles and i
i felt like i was doomed
it was just the brake dust is a big part
of it because it's so the particulates
of the brake dust on the cars are so
fine they get in the avioli of your
lungs
right into the blood barrier like just
right way worse than the carbon monoxide
um and that can cause hypertension and
stress
but you're compacted and there's nowhere
to run like if you're in manhattan
you can't really get out if they shut
down the bridges you can try and swim
the east river but if they don't want
you to they'll be looking for people
well so my point is i don't know about
you know
turning manhattan into a prison but my
point is great movie by the way
for people who for the for many rural
people which is the predominant is
predominantly conservative it's not
been as bad no no people but you know
what
am i going to shed a tear over these
gluttonous entitled silly city-dwelling
folks who demand
i'm sorry man when i see people illegal
immigrants
uh picking figs in in southern southern
california i went down and i interviewed
people and i met
the the children of illegal immigrants
and they're like my family they pick fit
or dates or something
and they get paid 14 bucks an hour and
i'm like isn't it amazing that those
people are doing work
and these new york and la liberals who
write articles about brad pitt's junk
are making 50 000 a year and getting to
eat the fruits of your labor while they
do nothing
that's why the democratic party likes
this they like the cheap labor coming in
to do the real work where they can sit
and pretend they're doing work
as if writing an article about celebrity
gossip or garbage is producing something
of value for society other than wasting
their time
and the next echelon is the banking
people that work in finance that don't
do
anything but take meetings and have
lunch during the day and they
their their income is their they just
keep making money on their money they
keep getting like
interest and and so max was talking
about this the private the hedge fund
billionaires the private equity but i
just want to say i mentioned this before
that i have infinitely more respect for
the illegal immigrants who will cross
vascular of desert right on top of
trains for thousands of miles
because they love america so much than i
do for these people in these cities who
are like america's racist
i hate this country well i don't know if
they love america so much or they they
love
they they need opportunities so much
they i mean well but
not but i know what you mean but like i
don't think they have like a great look
it gives you the chance to not have to
love the country they're like you don't
have to stand for the pledge of
allegiance you don't have to say it you
can stomp on the flag and burn it on the
ground
this is a place for you to be your best
in general though
i mean in general there are people who
are like america i have to be there yeah
they're not talking about the founding
fathers they're not talking about our
constitution they're saying
this country is just good i respect
those willing to go on this dangerous
journey to come to find the american
dream
and the people in these cities who are
complaining america is awful
and then you add on top of that the
insult to injury of a bunch of these
people i knew in new york working for
these companies writing these articles
saying donald trump orange man bad
getting paid 50 60 70 000 a year and
those same illegal immigrants making
five bucks an hour and they're like
america's great so i it's funny that as
you're doing this you keep making this
gesture
in the garbage yes no exactly because i
think it's because i think
i think compounded to that and the
article i wrote last year about leaving
dc and i've been a city kid my whole
life but now i'm a country boy and i'm
learning
but i think compounded to that also is
that
we are a ten thousand fifty thousand
seven thousand year old species
and it's really the first time that
people have made a living
off of something that requires no manual
labor but it doesn't change our dna it
doesn't change our nature
and i feel like especially for guys if i
don't mean to sound sexist
but i feel like the city guys i know who
were most well adjusted
have some sort of physical outlet but if
you just
work all day on a computer and you go
home and you play video games and you
watch
tv and that's what you do after you do
well your only outlet of of
productivity or creativity or
masculinity is like a nasty yelp review
because
your barista got your order wrong right
now you need an outlet you
you talked about the garden you talked
about chickens people men and women you
need
something to do to create to hold in
your hand whether it's art whether it's
you need to do something and we have
whole society that does not produce
anything i think it's funny how many
people who watch the show
like sort of poke fun at us out here as
new
you know country folk sort of they're
like oh it's so cute hear you talk about
how you have no idea what you're doing
with those chickens
and but it's like smiling and laughing
like oh you'll figure it out
people in these cities ain't never going
to figure it out because they're living
in their concrete cubicles that smell
like sour milk complaining
and demanding resources from outside
outside the cities
what i really love about the arguments
from a lot of these leftists when they
say well the cities are the ones that
produce
you know all of the gdp and everything
it's like okay let me let me explain
something to you
farms aren't in cities they're outside
the cities the food you eat
it's being imported it's being driven by
truck drivers not in those cities how
about your energy
your energy is produced not in your city
pipeline originates in the country
and you look at some of the jobs in
these cities i got to tell you man i'm
i'm hung up on this because i remember
the first time i went
i went to one of these news at rooms
when i worked for vice
and the job i had before vice was
non-profit office
which was not paid very well
um better than i've been paid working
for the airlines and a lot of hard work
it was very stressful people couldn't
handle the job because it was sales
basically
and so then i remember you know i had
worked for 10 bucks an hour at o'hare
airport
lifting heavy bags like 50 000 pounds of
luggage every day just eight hours
and then i walk into this vice newsroom
and i see half the chairs are empty and
i'm like oh where is everybody and
they're like oh they're working from
home
i'm like working from home how much do
they get paid forty thousand dollars a
year
i'm like 40 thousand what do they write
well sometimes i'll write like an
article or two per day
i'm like about what like brad pitt's
junk yeah that i'm like
wow so you guys are like elysium you
know i think i think i worked there
before the movie came out remember but
it's like where that space station where
all the rich people live
and they have like all this technology
you come into the office when you feel
like it
you write stupid articles about trash
and you get paid 40 grand a year
not a lot of money i understand but for
someone who's in the early 20s relative
to somebody's got to like i don't know
be a janitor
you look at some of these jobs in new
york where a guy's like changing light
bulbs you get like a 45 year old or you
know custodian he's like doing work and
his 20 year old's getting paid twice as
much as he is to write
nonsense yeah garbage now at least that
person
so so i'm gonna we'll keep this going
that person
you could say theoretically is producing
something
i think i feel more disgust
for the consumer side because that
person is only producing because someone
is clicking on that article
and who are these hundreds of thousands
of people more disgusting who have
nothing yeah they have nothing better to
do than they're like oh brad pitt's junk
seven times your cheeseburger reminded
you of brad pitt's job
exactly so there are clearly enough
people
who are clicking on that and that is
where our society has become like so i'm
producing content because there are
enough people
who have the largesse why do they have
the largess because we have 150
000 illegals every day across every
month across on the border who are doing
all of the labor that's right that
allows them the luxury
to click on brad pitt's junk articles
and it's funny because i hear the
argument from conservatives
when they raided that chicken processing
plant the guy was like i want to work
you know i want to make money and the
left says nobody wants those jobs
no it's just your entitled disgusting
lazy attitude you don't want that job
a ton of americans want that job a ton
of americans would kill for that job
well now you know i guess fortunately
for most people joe biden says
come on man just give everybody money
for no reason so now people are relying
on what's point working
yeah those will be the ones if the
zombie apocalypse came
who i mean they would die within the
first couple hours
right like you said how we would die it
would be the zombies yeah they probably
would
they would be they would be the zombies
they already are the zombies but like
like just think of
if if we did lose fossil fuels like that
and you said within days millions of
people would be dead
i think millions of 15 and 16 year olds
would be dead because their parents
would kill them
because they can't snapchat they can't
tick-tock they can't
and and oh they'd break down their heads
well right look these kids would be
insufferable so you just have to put
them down
a bunch of these gen z kids grew up
attached to the internet
if if the grid went down they would have
serious episodes i mean
during the lockdown this is crazy a
bunch of teenagers committed suicide i
know and
tragically some some people like i know
lost children and it's
i'm not gonna say any names or anything
but yeah these these stories because
they got disconnected from
their friends it's crazy what would
happen if we actually had some kind of
real crisis
and i tell you i don't think any i i
think most conservatives are
particularly confident in their
abilities for good reason and i think
most democrats are confident in their
abilities
out of ignorance i i these people who
grew up in cities man
they they think they'll be okay they
scoff and they left so we did the promo
for the food things
for the food buckets safe and
readymeals.com and
we i hear it from these leftists
laughing mocking me saying he's so dumb
selling these emergency food bins to
stupid people and i'm like
what do you think is going to happen
when i don't know like a heavy rainfall
hits
and i remember it was i think it was
houston or dallas where they had severe
flooding
and people were trapped in their homes
and i'm like do you think emergency food
is only for when the zombies come
or is it because sometimes it rains and
they're so
arrogant they always believe that food
is infinite
that they can walk into the store and
food's just there this is really great
um comedic bit this video where a guy
he like wakes up on his couch and
there's garbage everywhere
and his girlfriend walks in and she's
like what are you doing clean up the
garbage he goes no no no wait wait i
gotta show you something it's amazing
you just put the garbage right here on
the table you go to sleep
and when you wake up it's gone this
works by the way and she's like
what and he's like watch and he goes to
sleep and then he wakes up and it's gone
and she's gone
yeah and the joke was she's doing the
work you just don't know it so these
people think they can walk downstairs
and there's just food in the bodega
and i i love it when i was talking i was
arguing with ubi people
and they were like if we have ubi then
people can buy food and i was like
if you shut down the businesses and the
farms can't produce milk
and the milk can't get transported to
the store where does the where does the
milk come from
i kid you not someone tweeted food comes
from the store what are you talking
about
yeah there you go i was like what have
you ever seen the trucks pull in and
unload this
have you tried i was my mind was blown
where did the toilet paper is oh toilet
paper is
it still they were saying it's still
there it's just they have to restock it
because from
in the back do you think that like a
genie walks in the back and goes like
in like toilet paper it just appears and
they walk it out and put it on the
aisles
apparently a lot of people don't realize
that your avocados they come from mexico
they got to ship that from mexico to new
york so you can have your hipster
avocado toast
it's terrible for the environment by
their standards especially
and uh they don't care you know what i'm
most excited about is vertical farms i
i kind of want to get back to talking
about how ridiculous people are too yeah
but vertical farms are you guys familiar
with aerofarms in new jersey newark
biggest
indoor vertical farm in the world at
least it was a few years ago so
they grow food without dirt they'll like
the roots will grow in like a mesh and
they'll spray nutrients on the mesh
you have these like just floors and
floors and floors of indoor
plants i think that's the future of of
urban living i think
hydroponics yes aquaponics let's let's
talk about this
california declares drought emergency
across vast swath of state
we talked a lot about political crises
but what happens
so uh let me let me learn something i
don't want to blame joe biden for
everything
i think he's a bad leader i think his
policies have caused very serious
problems with the economy and with the
border of course
i don't think we can blame him for
everything having to do with israel and
gaza that would be insane that convo has
been going on for a long time
but what we're looking at now with this
story from california there's a massive
drought
i look at some of these photos and i was
i went and covered the drought several
years ago
when it was you know in its in its peak
it was it was a disaster
and it looks worse now i mean maybe i'm
wrong maybe maybe it's just
misremembering but it seems like it's
way worse what are we going to do now
when we have this pathetic
president who has no ability to lead how
is he supposed to deal with his own
problems of his creation
and with natural disasters because
california's
they're already in trouble yeah now you
add this drought
they're going to start going to other
states and making demands and they're in
demand relief they're mad we pay for it
that drought that you said you covered
and i'm trying what was that about
probably about a decade ago well no no
2016.
20 the 2015 2016. what steps did the
state of california ordered america take
after that drought to say how do we make
sure this doesn't happen again
right like i said earlier on one of the
things i challenge my challenge in this
industry is that it's not always
sexy it's not titillating it's not fun
that's another exam and this
is the role of government right the role
of government is not to police your
pronouns
it is not to talk about your your your
boys and girls in sports
these are for good or for ill these are
the jobs we've put at the feet of our
government
what has california or the country done
to secure our electric grid to secure
our energy supply
or in the case of california to secure
its water supply because you know you
are drought prone
you know what your population is you
know that the the rain is cyclical
i want to make sure i highlight the
other story in this because this is
about the greater natural disasters and
we have this one from
express.uk solar storm traveling at 1.3
million kilometers per hour to hit earth
tomorrow oh great
they say it could spark
satellite-related issues sometimes when
we get these when we get these storms it
causes issues with like cell phone
coverage and things like that
i don't think this is the big one where
all of our electronics get fried or
anything
but just another example of outside of
the political crisis
and the government to your answer to
your question not doing anything about
it
and uh i'm not i'm not comfortable right
now
with a biden presidency of bite
administration as we're staring down the
barrel of natural disasters
middle eastern conflict economic crisis
migrant crisis
i'm actually what um what's the opposite
of comfortable um
uncomfortable isn't it disconcerted no
not not enough
agitated uh anxious and
genuinely concerned but you know i would
say i'm not
a uh particularly excitable
so when it happens i kind of laugh and
then i go and buy a bunch of bullets
you know you know that was my reaction
today like i did my segments
so i do my my you know you know hour and
20 minutes or so in the morning three
segments 10 1
and four p.m and afterwards i was like
do ammo.com let's see
nine millimeter hollow point let's see
45 acp oh yes and you got it no problem
there's a lot of shortages yeah yeah
it's been a little bit better it was
really bad last year but i was like i'm
going to buy a bunch of bullets
and then i got like some beans and rice
and i'm like you know what man
that's that's that's that's the
manifestation of my anxiety watching
abide in presidency and natural
disasters
i'm like time to buy some ammo you're
not wrong either the historically if you
ever i want to tell you about the sea
peoples have you guys ever heard of the
sea
peoples 1200 bc peoples yeah apparently
this unknown culture of humans 1200 bc
came from the from asia and just flooded
the mediterranean and wiped out and
murdered and destroyed
all civilization essentially as we know
it they don't know why
no one really knows anything about them
or where they came from or why they came
but what they think happened was a
series of events
it's never the big one it's very rarely
it's a volcano along with uh
three years of famine and then there's a
flood or there's a war
involved with a famine and then there's
a solar flare
or there's a fire and it's all these
things happening at once
that's what causes social collapse it's
not it's not the
the oil alone it's not the solar flare
alone it's not the war alone but it's
when they all
conflict and they're all happening right
now isn't that isn't that perfect
any moment they can all happen right now
we have to be on guard for that and
that's
and that's like why i think biden is
particularly bad for us
i i understand it's like so obvious tim
poole criticizing joe biden i get it
um i think trump had his problems but
joe biden is like
sitting in his wheelchair with his
little warm blanket and the sun going
like while like everything's on fire
yosemite erupts and then there's
uh if somebody erupts we got nothing to
worry about yeah we'll be back and
there's a wall
and a flood we all have masks so if
yosemite erupts we have we have masks it
could block out
at the very least other than the actual
i mean for for i don't know how long it
would block out the sun
um that would destroy a crop so you're
saying the secret bunker should be
hermetically sealable so that we can
go underground and yes indoor farms
prolong our suffering
indoor farms is a big part of it it's
going to be a race to get to mount
weather if if mount
if yellowstone uh and yosemite goes up
also we're getting offered
whether that's the station uh in
virginia it's actually
um uh right outside dc but that's what
the government built in the case of
nuclear
war mount weather you can see it it's
right there on the hill it's a secret
government it's not secret because
everyone knows what it is oh it's not
it's not what's
what's happening well it's on a mountain
and it's called mount weather and it's
it's one of those what actually happens
in mount weather no one is
that where the island is a government
bunker is that where the enclave is no
that's awesome
yeah you go if you go far west of the
mountains and there's like a yeah that's
what it is the thing that concerns me is
i don't think we should even talk about
if
it's when when yosemite erupts because
it will again in the future
volcanoes do it's overdue by only like
80 000 years
so there's nothing to worry about when
there's a conflux of events that causes
mass catastrophe on the surface of earth
hopefully we'll be on mars we'll be on
the moon web space stations but
yeah what are we where's our localized
infrastructure
i don't want to rely on a pipeline i
don't want to rely on an energy
source far away i mean where's my will
food my water
my waste just real quick yes mount
weather is what they use to model raven
rock which in fallout 3 for those that
are familiar with the game
is where the enclave which is the
remnants of the us government are based
yes after the nuclear apocalypse there
you go yeah that's always a real place
but they're not gonna let you in
well no we're gonna try to get in maybe
but but to your point though absolutely
if if
if societal collapse happens
it's it is every man for himself and
that is why teaching
self resiliency and and and independence
is a
is a virtue and i feel like what we are
cult inculcating as a culture
and i feel like what this president is
doing is inculcating
dependency we last night we will take
care of you about africa a lot and like
i think nigeria how they're on crypto
and a lot of what's happened in these
african countries is they've
leapfrogged the last 100 years of
electrical infrastructure because they
didn't have
a central grid so they just immediately
went to solar panel on every house
and now they all have cell phones bypass
yeah yeah they bypass like the telephone
uh you know centralization structure so
they have cell phones
solar panels they're using crypto so
there is potential for new societies to
have
to start with you know sustainable stuff
as we can see in the gravity lights
gravity lights are really cool you ever
see those
no it's a series of gears and that you
have a rock
on a string okay and you lift the rock
up and let it go
and as the rock is falling it's spinning
the gears which
generate electricity and it falls right
in 12 hours yeah it takes 12 hours to go
all the way down there's a
lights it turns the light on so it's
like an old clock like an old
right right clock that has a pendulum
and then has yeah
so it's just using gear a gear you know
ratio
so that as it's spinning it goes really
slow it spins really fast and then
and gravity like the thing about
something in orbit is it's falling
technically when you're when you're
orbiting the earth you're in a state of
falling so if we could utilize that
force
to create electricity i think that oh
yeah sustainable you couldn't because
it is falling but it's moving forward
fast enough to where it
orbits you'd have to you'd have to
reduce speed at some point you can't
just
it that would be a perpetual motion
machine it wouldn't work you can't just
get energy out of the system it would be
perpetual it would slow down over time
but it might be slow down
like as the as the rock falls it takes
12 hours to fall maybe it could take
600 000 years for it to fall back to
earth i see just like orbital decay
mm-hmm
and then you like capturing that somehow
i don't know maybe
seems kind of crazy yeah but uh maybe
we'll get by a solar storm and then
it'll get
erased i think it wiped out going back
to the california
droughts i mean there are whole
countries i'm thinking of israel
that have mastered desalinization yeah
but you know the problem with that is i
actually why can't we in california
they do have one in carlsbad i went
there it's beautiful it's it's crazy
it's a whole bunch of
it's a series of tubes as most things
are i suppose uh the internet the old
pipelines but they have a whole bunch of
these tubes where the water runs
through all of them the problem is there
is going to be refuse
brine yeah and it we watched it we
filmed it as it poured out of these
these wastewater pipes
the brine sinks to the bottom and goes
under the ocean water
killing everything on the ocean floor
and that causes a wave of death going
all the way up
because the food chain dies the the
critters that eat stuff on the floor die
because there's no food anymore the
critters that eat those critters die the
criticism of those critters that die
and then the people who go fishing can't
get fish anymore so there's a lot of
things to solve with uh desalination
one of the ancients i suppose is humans
consuming more and more of the ocean
water
changing salinity destroying coastal
areas destroying fisheries
i don't think there's a salute there's a
solution for
infinite growth or at least exponential
growth considering how many people there
are i think there's a certain point
where we just get too many people and
then we strain
our ecosystem it happens to deer it
happens to
you know basically every creature on the
planet hogs for instance people go
around helicopters shooting hogs just
too many of them
humans are not going to be immune from
the same environmental forces that
everything else on the planet is
and so we've got to pay attention to
that i'm not going to print into the
solutions but i can tell you a lot of
really
crazy people are willing to do a lot of
really crazy things
once they get power to ensure that they
get to live comfortably forever
and you are the one who is the hog being
cold yeah
they're the ones who have the private
jets and the that's right
the multiple this is what i think this
is what i think about the climate change
thing i think a lot of these people are
like
you know there's like a guy and he's
like cities wearing his like velvet
bathrobe or whatever in the morning and
he's sipping his his morning coffee with
a cigar
and then he sees the newspaper and it
says due to climate change people will
lose access to these luxuries and he
goes
heavens i have to give up my private jet
no make everyone else give it up so he
throws money and says everyone give up
all your luxuries give up all your
luxuries and he goes
once they all give up their luxuries and
they're flushing their toilets
and now you got to pee in the top of the
toilet to flush the rest of it because
we got to save water
i'll get to keep my yacht i'll get to
keep my private plane
it's better this way by the way that's a
wonderful accent of a rich person yeah
it was good i mean
that's just that's flawless rich people
naturally develop those accents
yes as soon as you break your first
million in front of your mouth
you can watch it happen you should go to
a club and there'll be a guy and he's
like
well i'm looking at uh my portfolio here
and uh
oh it's about to cross one million
dollars oh my god
it's happening surely good oh rufus your
voice broke i see you've made a million
dollars
there's a woman and she's like oh you
made a million dollars and he's like you
can tell can't you
when the when the rich psycho says i
need to
rule all these these sycophants these
people
because they're not smart enough and
then they make these decisions like they
give up their
what's that bloomberg yeah yeah so when
that happens i wonder like then you were
talking about all these people that just
can't stop eating crap
salty fast food they can't like bring
themselves to change to become
self-identified to cook their own food
to take control of their life
are they really like a mass of
ignoramuses that need to be
controlled and called not called but
like taken taken care of by
a small group of highly intelligent
humans or is that a story we're told
that's a really good point i think uh
maybe you're onto something ian there
could be a group of people that
maybe just have better ideas it could be
a reference to like enlightenment
or you know like like a light like an
illumination
they could call themselves something
like that like an illumina illumination
guys or something
the illuminati illuminati yeah yeah the
ones who know all things
yes yes and they can tell other people
how to live
because as we've seen throughout history
centralization of power
always is a good okay if you hoard all
your information on an island then
there's no chance the island will get
flooded and destroyed and that the
information will be lost
or in a great library perhaps uh the
problem with these people is that
while i think it's true there are a lot
of really really dumb people and i think
there are very few
smarter people centralization
doesn't work one person a small group of
people
cannot adequately plan for how a system
this large will work
they've tried it over and over again it
was called communism
it clearly doesn't doesn't work it
didn't work and i know all these comey
leftists will be like that was because
the u.s was interfering with it it was a
real
communism yeah so yeah when they were
like starve the ukrainians to give the
russians food because we need it more
i'm like
that's central planning so when you're
treating individual like traffic that
maybe since the problem is not that
they're making people do something or
making them
not do something it's that they're
restraining their ability to be
adaptable
because yeah that's what you need to
allow people to centralization
strain their ability to be free yeah i
mean adaptability is freedom
and you know and then that's that's
taken away in a centralized system it's
it's interesting
uh max the other day was talking about
how these these um
alt coins like a casino somebody says i
put in money on this cryptocurrency i
lost money
and now i need to make it back up so
they put in a different currency they
keep losing money
i feel like a lot of the centralization
we see with these these these
wealthy individuals is they made a bet
hey we should do this policy
and control this good it'll make
everything better then when it gets
worse they go quick quick do another
policy
and so they keep stacking duct tape onto
a thing the problem is caused by them
yeah yeah and you talked about how it's
a series of events that lead to the
ultimate collapse of society
and i think you're absolutely right but
if you look at one country in particular
and more should be written about there's
movies you talked about doing original
creative
oh we're doing it movies should be
written about this and it is
in our lifetime the story of venezuela i
mean in in the turn of the century
this century the year 2000 it was the
the wealthiest most prosperous
country in south america uh um it had a
number of
of american and european engineers and
doctors who lived there
hugo chavez did not run as saying i'm
going to destroy your country he ran as
i'm going to bring a greater sense of
equality and equity or whatever whatever
and here we are 21 years later and 70
with the latest statistic i saw
78 percent of the population is in
extreme poverty
i mean they have the world's largest
proven oil and gas reserve
oil reserves and they have no they have
no oil not a murder though like a lot of
murder
exactly i mean i mean in the in every
single
those who who those illuminati those who
were smart those who were
fled the country and what is left and
who takes care of those people and that
that is i fear the direction we are
slowly headed in it's a series of
collapse in addition to the series of
collapses what happens
what tends to happen is it will affect
one large group of people and then those
people will
migrate because they're screwed and then
the migration will cause another
catastrophe where they land
and they'll disrupt those that
population the sea people were the ones
that were catastrophically
affected by the series of events so it
seems but the people that were murdered
in the mediterranean just suffered the
fallout
so what you're basically saying is that
in these blue areas destroyed by
democrats they're all going to flood
into red air we're seeing it happen
and they're bringing their weird you
know race theories
it's like a drop of it it's it's landing
in schools in like west virginia
freaking out parents
yeah colorado yeah and that's why
federalism is your best fight back
because
you have so much more power at this
power should be as concentrated at the
localest level possible and people
get rid of the electoral college you
know i mean without getting into the
history of our founding fathers
the person who's not elected by
electoral college is your governor
because that's where
more power should be than the president
they never wanted the president they
never wanted dc to be powerful
so did the founders love democracy they
love direct democracy because they
wanted it at the most local your mayor
is elected by direct democracy
but boy wouldn't it be great if your
mayor had more power than your governor
and your government more power than the
president
but instead they used to be an
expression my mom i hope you're
listening mom
she used to say it all the time and
maybe she's the last one don't make a
federal case out of it
we don't say that anymore everything is
now a federal case
my trans daughter can't play volleyball
go to the supreme court
holy crap there's no other recourse
everything gets elevated
to washington dc well it that's that
that's it's like we're asking
you know mom and dad to solve our
problems for us yeah that's it's an
interesting thing you know the problem
is if people live in these awful blue
states
then they move to red states and then
start floating voting blue again and
then they just
you know keep yeah and then maybe we'll
move back to california one day and
reclaim it as our own
right i mean there are states that were
blue that have turned red and there are
states that are red that are turning
blue
and and i'm not going to stop migration
patterns but you know california
had the largest exodus in the last 10
years
who knows maybe they'll drive it so far
into the ground people will start moving
back to california and reclaim it
yeah well how about we take some super
chats so if you haven't already
smash that like button and leave your
comments because it really does help and
don't forget to become a member at
timcast.com
to get access to our massive library of
members only content you can see in the
members area
we got a ton of really awesome stuff
from a lot of really great people we'll
have a bonus coming up tonight let's
read
some super chats but again don't forget
to share this show and smash that like
button i said that already
all right let's see we got here mike
sullivan says mr biden recently met
jimmy carter
carter told him about the amazing gas
lines he had joe said
hold my geritol and watch this and now
we have
gas lines again that's fantastic
wolfstar says tim will never stop
selling fear to his audience he is worse
than the msm
you're entitled to your opinion i
disagree the mainstream media is
outright lying to you about what's going
on
and it's really funny when i have people
who say like oh tim you said all these
things were going to happen i'm like
some approximation of those things are
literally happening
last year when i was like man i'm really
concerned about shortages you know so
check out this emergency food stuff
don't go crazy just you know have some
emergency food water and a first aid kit
and then we got all this news about
supply shortages at all these major
chain stores and i'm like okay the
apocalypse isn't here but like
it's important to pay attention to the
stuff if you don't like it hey man
you're entitled to your opinion you
don't got to watch the show nobody's
making you do it
all right let's see john lee says tim
today
when typing your channel your newly
uploaded videos didn't show up i had to
go into your channel to find the video
did something happen
more importantly where's my chicken
stream uh i don't know i guess youtube
nuked the video it happens sometimes and
often look into it i guess
uh the chicken stream is we're working
on it i guess
all all good things are worth the wait
right that's right
tango hotel says tim i heard your call
to create new culture i'm a disabled vet
and i create every day at twitch
tango hotel where i stream xcom2
longwear and a variety of other games
thank you for for all of uh for what you
do appreciate it xcom long war is so
legit
so good unreasonably angry says hey
daniel as a trucker
i would like to hear your expert opinion
on what the next step is for trucking
electric hydrogen sell or stick with
diesel
um you probably know this a lot better
than i do but the reason why i have
hesitancy to say that we're going to go
all electric with trucking
uh is because of the size and the of the
battery the weight
and the amount of of space it takes up
in the truck so
people say we're gonna have a fleet of
electric trucks one day when i look at
what uh truckers carry in terms of
especially fossil fuels but other things
that are extremely
heavy payloads not your amazon truck not
your ups truck that is not ex
but really really heavy payloads there
will not there is not yet a battery
strong enough to run that truck that may
happen one day i'm not opposed to it
again and let technology take its place
but right now i think the trucking
industry is
the way our economy runs i think our
trucking industry is
is very safe even though i was
advocating for the pipeline for fuel
transportation
truckers don't have to worry about their
future in the immediate future they
don't know
damon cord with probably the best
comment so far
there is no war in bossing say also
don't forget hurricane season is right
now yeah keep in mind
uh for those aren't familiar with that
reference there's no war embossing say
it comes from the avatar show
where they go to this great big city
called basing say which is literally
being attacked but
or there's a war with the fire nation
but the government doesn't allow people
to talk about it
they're just like shut up nothing's
happening and uh that was
a great story arc and now american
capitalist says hyperinflation has hit
the used vehicle market
there was a youtube short of a 65 000
corvette with 15 miles being flipped for
100k
dealerships are empty my three-year-old
truck's trading value is higher than it
was brand new
whoa wow wow
turk longwell says tim i think max and
stacy may have convinced me to go
straight bitcoin especially with all the
disaster talk lately love the show smash
that like button
you know what man i've known about
bitcoin for a decade
and every step of the way i was like if
only i had bought some if only i had
bought something if only i bought some
at a certain point i was like man i'm
stupid because if only i had bought some
i'm like okay i'm buying some
yeah you know i i i have a little bit
from a long time ago
and it's kind of crazy to see something
that was not worth that much not be
worth so much and i'm just like wow
but i never man i i wish back in 2012
when i was like five bucks or whatever i
hit five bucks and i was like ah it's
way too expensive to buy now
because people don't get it and i didn't
get it and i knew about it
yeah if only back then so i'm i think
bitcoin's gonna hit a million bucks
uh bitcoin has one and then eight zeros
after it that comes out to with you know
two to
a decimal point two zeros a million
dollars so i think it'll reach around
that point probably
uh sooner than people realize so uh i'm
buying bitcoin and i was thinking about
it too
i'm probably just going to start trading
bitcoin as if it is worth a million
dollars
so what that means is like if someone's
like you know hey i'll give you you know
x
you know point zero zero zero whatever
the bitcoin for x amount of dollars it's
like wow someone handing me
you know a hundred dollars for five
bucks you know what i mean i was gonna
buy a laptop
i mentioned this last night and instead
i just bought bitcoin
and i was like you know because i don't
want it in a year be like oh that was
the most expensive laptop i ever bought
i could have bought 10 laptops i could
have bought 15 laptops with this bitcoin
with this money that the opportunity
cost maybe if i buy it and every time i
come on the show can we can we
talk about where it is when i bought it
i mean yeah you'd be like hey we're up x
percent i'll go back to i'll go home
tomorrow i'll buy something
tonight and buy some i think max was
correct about bitcoin
people want it because it can store
value it doesn't matter
you know i i didn't realize this way
back in the day in 2011 when it was
really hard to buy like so i
probably would have bought it even
though my friend talked me out of it but
it was just difficult to get you'd like
arrange a meeting with someone who had
some
yeah i was actually mining on my
computer like oh this is fun
it was just like so small i i
you know people some guys bought a pizza
with like 20 000 bitcoin
and it didn't matter he got a pizza if
people just recognized
it did have value it doesn't matter how
many you have it's going to go up
i'm not telling anybody to buy it i'm
just saying ten years it went from
one cent to fifty thousand dollars sixty
thousand
ten years that's like nothing which
means if you put in
uh uh what if you bought 20 000 bitcoin
uh you'd be a billionaire right now and
when i when i first discovered bitcoin
it was at 70 cents
a billionaire 10 years billionaire you'd
buy a yacht
i told eddie earlier i was almost going
to buy it at 600 i guess it was like
eight years ago and i was like
600 is so much money right and my friend
was like buy
three coin and i was like oh my god are
you kidding me
of course i didn't buy it when it hits a
million
you're gonna be like but now it's like
56
000 but don't be turned off by the cost
of one yeah you buy it in percentage
percentages
no i'll probably dollars i'll buy 30 or
40 bitcoins
you can afford yeah something like that
sure take it away
good luck with that just throw me some
if you got that
here we go we got dr remylac says i did
an interview with the keystone pipeline
i lost a potential 70 thousand dollar a
year
job i am pissed well it's not all bad
seventy thousand dollars a year by next
year will only be twenty thousand so you
won't have lost that much money hey how
about that
they'll have to give you uh five hundred
thousand dollar your job
heart goes out to your brother making
those keystone pipeline videos
was one of the hardest things i did and
talking to those guys 70 000 is a great
salary i talked to guys who've been
working
as welders for 30 40 years they lost 300
000
jobs tragic yeah we got a lot of
comments from people
jay uh britain clark says democrats be
like there is no warren bossing
that's right wow shark bite biz says tim
can you give my vodcast sharkbite biz
some love there you go give a shout out
thanks for the super chat
vodcast crandall logan says there was no
gas shortage there is no massive
inflation
there is no food shortage there is no
war in boston there is no war in boston
yup you know why they're saying all
these things they don't want people to
panic
yeah and so i guess we're privileged
each and every one of you listening are
fortunate enough to
to hear these things before it breaks
out into the mainstream the new york
times put out a tweet that said there
are no long lines
that's crazy you you saw them you you
on the way here you saw massive lines
two or three uh and i'll see them when i
drive home tonight
and heck i will take a picture and uh
daniel turner ptf on twitter
and i'll post them i wanted to post them
but i didn't want to pull over right
so listen so i i have no problem reading
the criticism of me where the guy says
i'm selling fear by all means
if if that's what you think don't listen
to me
if you think we're making good points
then maybe you should check out
safeandreadymeals.com they sponsor the
show it helps us produce the show
and i genuinely think they're good
products we have a bunch of them
uh or don't by all means i could be some
raving lunatic on the internet who's
wrong about everything and you shouldn't
listen to me i'm just some guy with a
camera
and a bunch of other guys showed up and
we talk about stuff if there's a problem
on the horizon don't be afraid
and do not panic make a decision and
make it fast
you you can you can weather this there's
a great story where um i can't remember
exactly
what it was but you got people listening
probably know they were like there's
like a shipwreck and a bunch of soldiers
were on a boat
and they were freaking out and so then
one soldier took out his weapon and took
it apart
and then gave everyone a piece and then
took out a bunch of bullets and then
gave everyone
everyone else a bullet and then said
okay shut up we're gonna rebuild this
weapon
and then called on people who had the
right pieces at the right point
and i was reading about they said
psychologically it took people out of
panic mode
and put them into a logical mode they
all sort of stopped and were waiting for
their cue to participate in
the completion of a logical process that
allowed them to
plan better calm down and assess the
situation better
so panic is bad you never want to panic
when you panic
you run into a burning building or into
the direction so i'll give you a better
example i was in venezuela
and uh on one side of the street down
the block we had a bunch of venezuelan
national guard
armed guns one block down a bunch of
protesters
the protesters all start screaming and
they all start running north
i ran west because i didn't panic
when people people in the situations and
they panic they all run in the same
direction
it's like imagine a boulder is behind
you and you're like i better keep
running straight
yeah that's panicking you should maybe
take one step to the right and let it
pass you by
your chickens do that all the time and
you're like just go to the left
i'm i'm walking to that door and the
chicken just keeps in front of banging
and
like go to the left or the right and you
eventually have to stop yeah
it doesn't make you think it's funny
because we have this little thing for
the chickens
it's like a little fence area the gate
is open
and the the chicken friends will all
walk out
and walk they'll come out to the right
where the gate is open then go forward
and turn to the left
and then the one chicken inside is just
poking its head at the fence panicking
freaking out not understanding why it
can't get through and then i'm like i
can't tell the chicken
the door is there they're just not smart
enough and then it just stops and just
craps right where it's standing and i'm
like all right you know
there's no help in these things i guess
you can give them food and water but
they're funny to watch yeah that's the
phenomenon of herd animals and like
hurting is weird how animals run in a
pack together straight forward when they
freak
not all of them silence do good says
yeah that is totally false i oversee one
of the largest manufacturing plants in
the world
there is no shortage in petroleum
drivers i have thousands under my
supervision it's a hoax trust me
if that's true then what's going on hey
who were all these people reporting
i didn't see it it didn't happen that's
right yeah that's my point
i got an idea i looked out the window i
didn't see a line there are no lines
yeah hold on hold on
i'm going to choose to ignore this super
chat and just pretend we didn't read it
yeah there's a truck driver shortage
what do we do
well i don't know if that's where this
person is but right could have been
sarcastic that
you never know although the arg in your
defense and in the articles defense it
did say
particularly oil and gas uh truck
drivers because they do need special
certification and those schools were
shut down
again the implications of shutting
everything down for kovid we have a we
have a clarification apparently so
remember what it said it said trucker
shortage but then it said the trucks
were parked
right not the same thing uh cj hansen
says
truck mechanic here there's no driver
shortage the emission trucks aren't
reliable
and fail monthly as if on schedule the
parts aren't available
and they don't run without a fully
functional emission system
parked trucks could it be a supply
shortage instead
well it's very similar to the chip
shortage that we're facing we've been
i've been trying to get this computer
for a long time
we've been waiting for over a month and
i don't fault the company they're like
we're just sorry
i'm like look we want this particular
processor i don't want to
buy a machine that's going to fail on us
or just not be reliable enough as we
expand because we want to do the shows
outside so we want a good machine that
can handle a lot
and they're like then we're going to
have to wait and i'm like i guess we
have to i guess we have to wait
it's getting freaky out there man oscar
olyu says nc residents do tend to panic
by if there is snow there is no milk or
bread the same day
also sheep coin ship coin go new puppy
coin also
used to hate ian but he's grown on me
down with the fed i think shiba ino is a
token
not a coin okay and in which case i say
at least uh uh dogecoin is an actual
coin yeah
tokens operate their issue 20 erc20
tokens they operate on ethereum and
people can just like snap their fingers
and
there's like a million of them there's
going to be 370 trillion
sheba tokens i think 370 trillion
trillion it's in the trillions the
amount they're gonna print
it's like it's like it's like it's a big
number a thousand times it's
look it's people just trying to i i
don't think dogecoin is the greatest
coin ever
because doge it's just going to keep
making they're going to keep making
mort's inflationary i get that
but it is at least still to a certain
degree decentralized
there's not a lot of infrastructure
happening on it there's not a lot of
work being done on it but these these
tokens man
i don't i don't know about this humor
the human and humor like it's part of
what we are so
does coins like it's like a comedy coin
it's so crazy
this world did yeah uh another person ai
says
uh l there is no truck driver shortage
regulations make the job very
frustrating
i'm about to get my license suspended
over my logbook time to leave
wow it's almost like policy is shutting
this stuff down
exactly this is the power of government
regulation this is when we need
adaptability disasters
freedom yes federalism that's right
a lot gaming channel says a la gaming
channel i
watched yesterday's live and you were
talking about ubi i'm not really a huge
yang fan anymore but every time you
mention ubi it shows you don't really
know much about his actual policy
or you just choose not to know i
disagree i think i know a decent amount
because i followed him extensively and
donated to him a lot
and i understand his policy position
it's a thousand bucks a month for every
american and they forego
other welfare in exchange for this this
ubi
the problem is there are a lot of people
who just want money
yeah i've heard he's gonna he wanted to
put a vat tax on corporations so like at
every point in the supply chain the the
cotton is grown and shipped to the the
cotton manufacturer there's a
there's a tax taken out that's part of
the value added the manufacturer ships
it to the store there's a value-added
tax taken out then the store sells it to
the person there's a value-added tax
taken out but then what's going to
happen the concern is that if he puts
that in place
the corporations are going to raise the
prices to compensate for that tax of
course so the cost of the
product is going to go up and then he
gives everyone a thousand bucks and then
eventually a thousand bucks can't buy
anything anymore
and so then people say a thousand isn't
enough we need two thousand there's two
thousand and then here we go
you'd have to dictate that the
corporations can't raise their prices
which is like fascist you don't want the
government
the yes sorry i mean to cut you off
you're right
that's what it is otherwise i love the
concept but man i
i i don't even like job economy and
money getting headed towards a better
place
i mean it is a myth to think that the
corporations pay corporate taxes biden
keeps talking about we're going to raise
the corporate tax rate
did they really think that like like
ford motor companies like oh boy guys
we're not going to make as much money
this year we got to pay a higher tax
bill or are they just going to jack up
the price of every single car they're
not going to pay
or go or go to mexico yeah or go to
mexico my biggest problem with yang if i
can just say really fast i was home for
mother's day in new york city where my
family is from where i was born and
raised
blah blah blah i saw a lot of his
commercials on tv um
i don't like ubi but i hate the fact
that his his commercials are about
we're going to invest in kids and make a
better tomorrow and ubi and i'm like
have you looked around new york like
that is not the problems facing new york
eric yang and every andrew
andrew injury andrew yang or anyone else
running for gov for mayor
it was just total disconnect sorry dr
doctor says
climate change is to democrats what 911
was to republicans for dams it is a
vehicle to gain control of industry for
republicans it was a vehicle to trample
on personal privacy rights
instead of ubi what about negative
income tax by milton freeman
perhaps here's here's a good one uh
seven om cruz
says what is your opinion on thorium
molten salt reactor
holy cow um i don't really have an
opinion on that i
i uh i consider myself a pretty
well-versed expert on
fossil fuels and on renewables but that
is outside of my pay grade so i
apologize i'm not going to be able to
answer is that
my my general understanding is that
they're excellent new technologies that
will
generate a massive energy return on
energy invested
better than uh i don't think it's better
than petroleum right uh nuclear
yeah it's not but it is really high and
the other thing i the only thing i know
about thorium is that it's one of those
things that for 40 years we've been
talking about but no one's ever seemed
to have been able to bring it together
yeah people can well as regulations so
they're asking me to talk about on the
show i get messages i think it's not
radioactive but it gets hot
so you can use it to melt salt and boil
salt which will then cause steam
and crank turbines and the salt doesn't
evaporate like water does
interesting and then we could desalinate
water and use that salt to fill tanks
but there would be dirt brine and other
things so we have to purify it
yeah interesting all right let's see
what we got here uh balian says tim i
have friends that worked on keystone
a lot of those leaks were thought to be
due to sabotage people who would come by
uh drill halfway into the pipe and when
it was turned on it would blow the rest
of the way through
and i wouldn't be surprised if that was
the case absolutely believe it no
eco-terrorism is a real problem it's
been a problem for 30 years in this
country
yep because people are just dumb there
was a there was a post
i'm not going to name the organization
where they they wrote an anonymous
article on how to derail trains
it's like oh great that's that's stuff
they they're they're just lunatics
i played civilization two and one of the
units was the eco terrorist i was like
what that's horrible but it was like
well these nuclear plants are causing
all this pollution and they want to stop
the pollution so they kind of made them
seem like the good guy oh they always do
yeah
why are they called terrorists because
they're blowing stuff up
always good to blow up a nuclear plant
yeah that was the the
final fantasy vii you played as an
eco-terrorist in that game it was like
super popular game
and this is why we're losing the culture
war yeah
ex uh lb butcher says as a former as
former private contractor just having a
gun for protection is silly
look up james yeager modern minute man
you need
to feed the rifle with love all right
let's see where we're at here true nana
shop out of pressure bettacafcare says
they are never going to sell me on
destroying our country because
because of climate change when they
won't say anything about china i hear
you
greatest username ever
silence do good says sounds like tim is
realizing the same thing joe rogan is
this is extremely dangerous your staff
and guest as well said
you don't have to be a republican you
just have you just have to be a loving
person to see
i'm not a republican i get called a
token republican a lot but i don't
i don't think i am how do you identify
politically what do you do i
i guess if i had to call myself as
something i would like to call myself a
federalist i mean they existed back at
the beginning of the country
but i truly believe in in in federalism
and the most local
all power as as concentrated at the
localist level as possible federalist
does not mean you empower the federal
government it means you empower the
local government
yeah it is it's it's it's the the
principle under which our country was
supposed to be founded
and which we lived for a long time until
the civil war
and then we concentrated everything in
dc because we were afraid of states
going rogue again
and then we built on that and built on
that and then you got an fdr and then
you got a
lyndon johnson and you got a george bush
and and here we go
yeah degall says hybrid vehicle
technology diesel generator in a car
driving electric motors through a
generator
less fuel than internal combustion but
allows electric vehicle tech to develop
alongside fossil fuel
phase out instead of instant industry
destruction that sounds like
you'd lose energy though because you're
you're converting it two steps
instead of using the combustion
immediately for mechanical energy for
kinetic energy you're converting it to
electricity
with mechanical energy and then to you
know electromagnetic
force it seems like yeah and every
conversion you lose a large percentage
of potential energy
neighbor says tim i heard your comment
the other night i am that fat truck
driver from dubuque you mentioned and i
am not racist i thought you would like
to know
so i just was like shouted out like you
know the working-class guy is like a fat
truck driver from dubuque and they're
calling him a white supremacist because
he voted for trump
but he's not a racist but he's but he's
not that's the point it's like a regular
working-class guy he's like
not a racist what the democrats say is
samuel eddy says we will build communist
crushing robots with capitalist steel
it's proven that it's better quality and
higher tech and we can get paid to do it
what was uh uh liberty prime from three
no what is that you're looking the wrong
way too i don't
i'm sorry in fallout 3 so uh
that to fight the communists the us
built a giant robot called liberty prime
and it's like yelling things about
crushing communists giant robot
nice hilarious best robot ever let's
build it that's right
[Laughter]
someone may have done it readout
production says daniel thoughts on
nuclear energy energy going forward in
the u.s
i don't get why green energy people
reject nuclear so hard it seems to be
a bridge to their goal to get pure green
why ignore nuclear attacks
isn't it crazy how like in in the green
new deal nuclear energy is also
banned like the the green movement does
not consider nuclear to be
well it's green it's because it's a
solution to their problem yeah exactly
that's true i look i i always go to the
example of of france
that gets around 90 of their electricity
from nuclear power
and if the french can do it no offense
to france the french can do it
america certainly could do it i think
the concern is meltdowns
of thorium so it's like the type of
nuclear because there's fusion there's
thorium those are both nuclear reactions
nuclear power but when you have like
uranium nuclear power
that melts down and the aquarium burns
through the melts through the stone
encasing into the earth and then into
the dirt and goes into the in
is radioactive no not yet thorium
doesn't do that but
i think they're afraid of uranium uh
nuclear power because of the meltdown
capability i've talked to so many
nuclear engineers who say that nuclear
capability now is nothing the way it was
30 40 50 years ago
but we've never been able to build it
but we have but only for the military
yeah we have nuclear-powered military
ships why can't we have nuclear-powered
cruise ships it's illegal all right
robert gonzalez says if blue states are
spending their money in red states
that's taking cash flow out of the blue
and adding it to the red state wouldn't
that strength strengthen the circulatory
cash flow in the red state
no because what happens is the red
states are working and producing things
the blue states aren't
and then the blue states get money
printed by the government
to go and extract the value from the
people working in the red states
and then once all of the money is out of
the blue states they'll cry again and
the government will print more money and
give it to them and then they'll go to
the red states where they're doing hard
work
and keep taking from them and there you
go that's the cycle
it's not that simple mind you but you
know there you go i love
again the left is like the cities are
generating the gdp because your cost of
living is so high and you write stupid
articles about brad pitt's junk does not
mean you are producing things sorry i
guess technically that is a product
it's not one i think we need not really
this episode should be called brad
pitt's junk
mm-hmm well that's like it's the go-to
mockery i do for for new york media yeah
you know yeah seven times your
cheeseburger looked like bread i just
watched a
clip from legends of the fall last night
you guys want to see that movie legends
of the phone yeah
and each page is only one photo you
gotta click next every time
37 clicks in one article yeah because
every other click is an ad and then it's
like
but you power through hey delamar says
sean parnell announces a bid for pa's
2022 u.s senate seat
oh be fine again yeah sean parnell's
great yeah you had him on the show
a couple times twice three times we're
having him on again
school dude
huge fan i've never met him he's gonna
definitely be great one of the people
yeah yeah one of the few candidates i
actually contributed to last like right
on yeah
his ad was amazing yeah walking through
the warehouse or whatever like the
dollar shave club yeah yeah model yeah
dollar shawn club
big fan oh i'm like a fan boy that's so
cool
joe sullivan says i'm a trucker working
the road right now truckers aren't
worried about fuel shortage
we can get fuel from farther out to make
sure we have enough tell people to not
worry about getting food and fuel tell
them to get the hell out of my way
there you go fair very fair
brony ninja says you should check out
dungeon full dive on kickstarter it
brings
it uh it looks to bring dnd to vr
they're blowing past stretch goals
regularly i've backed it for 1200 bucks
and i have and i'll have a painting of
myself in the lobby for my reward tier
wow that might be fun all right sounds
amazing
shark lunch says ian hammurabi was an
a-hole ruined women's rights
gudea was the better mesopotamian king i
didn't know that thank you
interesting yeah sometimes the greatest
kings were not good people
but they're remembered for what they did
not how they acted
i guess technically it's similar what
you do is how you act
yeah cwg aka jeremiah says while
hitchhiking
i heard about all of this going down and
i didn't want to go into the next town
because i thought i'd be killed
but i always needed more water now i'm
thinking about going out hitchhiking
again
good luck if you do i mean i don't know
if you're supposed to do that isn't it
like illegal can't hitchhike or
something you know i thought a good
movie
script would be people in
post-apocalypse looking for water and
they have to go deep underground in like
deep caves to search for it
uh are the sea people there yeah
something like that yes of course they
are see people
i want to learn more about the sea
people oh it's crazy i've never heard of
them
terrifying okay i always come up jeffrey
grunt says
there is no war embossing say don't you
mean who is john galt
yeah yes that too there is no war in
galt sculpture there are five lights
there are four lights there are four
lights in galt gulch where there's
nowhere there you go
gran takus says the labor shortage is
hard in the carpenter field i'm 19 and i
haven't seen anyone my age work in the
field i started when i was 12 working
with my dad
i worked all across southern ohio and
the youngest man i saw on the field was
22.
check this out they're giving people
16 an hour not to work that means there
are a lot of people who
who should be working who are young and
need to start developing these skills
there is a year where there's going to
be a gap in basic
trade skills you think that's just going
to just disappear
i don't know what is going to happen in
10 years we're going to have stunted
trades we're going to have a period
where it's like
who's going to fix your toilet who's
going to build your house or repair your
the damage to your house or who's going
to help fix your car and the people who
should be learning how to do this didn't
work they skipped that year maybe
even two years like what's going on it's
still it's still happening yeah two
generations
yep it's concerning because not two
generations just two years
it compounds so if you don't know what
you're doing next year it's gonna be
harder to get better
you kind of almost take a step back if
you don't go forward yeah i'm really
worried about these kids who are missing
school that's really going to affect
them in the future oh absolutely
i hope they're okay it's like all these
parents that forced their kids to play
soccer
and the kid just wanted to learn how to
play the violin right and now we have
all these fat kids playing soccer and we
are missing a whole crop of violin
players
right it's like but my son plays soccer
put him in the darn violin so yes we're
like
we now we will miss all these trade
because we sent them off to go get an
economics degree i don't want to be an
economist i want to be a carpenter
uh-huh
can't do that big red says can confirm
gas is scarce in tennessee
premium and diesel only at every gas
station in my town outside of nashville
more because of panic buying than
anything else i'm sure yeah
i mean yeah kevin landa verde says ian
is the poor man's alex jones lol i love
alex
the poor man is so good well alex is
very wealthy
there you go ar says solar panel solar
panels are more environmentally harmful
than nuclear
produce more toxic waste metals
manufacturing them releases nf3 which is
a thousand times worse than co2
wow boom
there is no perfect energy but let's
just have that conversation
nf3 is that what i said nf3 nitrogen
fluorine perfect
energy what would perfect energy be yeah
we're all looking for it but we we
we talk about solar and wind like it's
flawless and a perfect solution and it's
not they have drawbacks
fossil fuels have drawbacks we live in
the real world we don't live in
fantasyland
this is called nitrogen trifluoride
tom just tom says diesel electric
hybrids are more efficient than
mechanical drivetrains
regenerative braking as energy saved c
trains
stored power in batteries and surface
area for solar
interesting i like it i have a prius i
love it i went from getting like 16
miles a gallon to 42
in los angeles all right so we'll just
do uh one more here we got
uh babada says yeonmi
park is a north korean defector youtuber
please get her on here call joe rogan
and get her on there as well
i i a lot of people are always telling
me like tim call joe rogan i can't just
call joe rogan and be like joe hey
here's here's your list of guests for
this month it doesn't work
that's not how things happen i would
like to have miss park on though but
that would be cool
absolutely especially with uh in the
event where there's any more you know
escalation or conflict happening
but all right let's see we can we just
grab we'll grab one more one more super
chat
uh okay just a simple question here from
rick bird he says have you talked about
what's happening
uh what have you talked about what me
happening
in israel you mean what is happening
israel only very a little only
a little bit i am uh not the biggest
expert or anything like that we
mentioned the 13-story building
crumbling
down and a lot of people are freaking
out about that it's not just people on
the left
i'm even seeing like defenders of
it's interesting right now a lot of the
pro-palestinian crowd on twitter
are condemning hamas and saying that the
palestinians are suffering
and i think i think it's right i think
it's the the actions of bad people
and then a lot of people at the same
time are criticizing israel for knocking
down a 13-story residential building to
go after some of these extremists
it's not a pretty situation man it's
hard it's hard to deal with but um
what's the gist
i was reading a little about it the
someone fired rockets and yeah hamas
fired just off volley the rockets these
videos are insane man
i i i know i i've i've had friends in
israel tell me the stories
when they're like sitting down in their
bedroom and also they hear explosions
and the air raid sirens go off and they
can see the shrapnel and
they have like iron dome the iron dome
defense is basically they fire missiles
at the missiles
and then they just unload and retaliate
and they're they're not completely
effective it's not even like
no they don't they go out there missile
sites and then the missile sites and
they'll hide the missile sites in like
residential areas schools and hospitals
and things like that so
it's complicated man it's hard missiles
could be like a shoulder mounted do they
do shoulder mounted no i don't think
i mean i don't think so no these are
these are pretty intense rockets that
are
traveling like 70 miles or more and
they're getting more and more advanced i
do have one question tim
wasn't palestine having a hard time
getting the vaccine because they didn't
have
funding because they seem to have a lot
of rockets for somebody
who doesn't have any funds there's a big
difference between the palestinian
people who are in
that's true crisis and the terror groups
who are smuggling
weapons from iran and things like that
or you know funded by but uh all right
well so
we'll leave it there make sure you
subscribe to this channel hit the like
button
hit the notification bell and go to
timcast.com because we will have that
bonus segment coming up at 11 p.m with
the
with more of the conversation we'll talk
about more of these stories you can
follow the show on facebook at
facebook.com
timcast irl you can share our videos
help the channel and you can check us
out on instagram at tim cast irl
we do the show monday through friday
live at 8 pm so thanks for hanging out
and again timcast.com you can also check
out that to the moon
dogecoin shirt we have pinned in the
chat which uh get one if you like i
think it's a pretty funny shirt
hey we don't we don't put doge under
anything it's just a shiba but it's
funny
uh you want to shout anything out daniel
yeah daniel turner uh
powerthefuture.com you can also see me
on social media at
uh twitter daniel turner ptf and it is
always great to be on this show it's a
great time and great conversation really
it's good to see you again man thank you
you guys in the chat you rock you super
chat
i love you guys that's so fun thanks for
coming i'm ian crossland you keep
meeting up at ian crossland.net you can
also check out
in our store the uh don't find an
alligator underwater mug
that's all right i have not confirmed
this yet but the art is fantastic
and i'm looking forward to getting one
for myself i don't know if these are for
sale but i got a hero
i don't think we sell those these are
really this is a special one of a kind
thanks whoever sent that thanks guys
awesome well i cannot wait to see that
mug
i'm really excited for all our new merch
and you can follow me at sarah patchlids
on twitter and join me in my quest to
have as many or more followers than sour
patch kids
and of course you can follow me at tim
cast across the board we will see you
all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you